[Music]
my
so
[Music]
a unique online event with enticing high
stakes the inaugural season of the rapid
chess championship delivered its fair
share of big names and big moments andy
karunakamura nakamura is going to win
how did he do that
with more than 50 grand masters claiming
cash prizes over six months of weekly
competition it was also home to a
healthy helping of big surprises e6
wandering up seven this has been such a
roller coaster awarding over half a
million dollars in cash money
but year one of the rcc is not done yet
the rapid chess championship is
presented by coinbase and the finals are
finally here
the brightest stars from the regular
season including hikaru nakamura fabiano
caruana alexander grisham and more are
back to take a run at a fresh 150 000
and the very first rapid chess
championship title
also in the mix the familiar faces of
top players known for dominating elite
online chess events
how will they handle the pressure of
chasing a championship
and crashing this party as wild card
invites some of the most famous names in
competitive chess drop in to stake their
claim to the thirty thousand dollar
first prize
my friends
it's the inaugural rapid chess
championship final
who will make history as our first rcc
champion what surprises are still to
come
we are soon to find out
welcome back to the rapid chess
championship finals presented by
coinbase i'm grand master robert hess
alongside me today just like yesterday
my good friend my co-commentator crime
grand master daniel naraditsky donya
yesterday we had some great matches
today's only going to get better yeah
terrible way to start the weekends
commentating the rapid chess
championship with a couple of amateurs
it's gonna be crappy as usual we've had
no excitement no time scrambles no
quality of play and i'm sure all of that
will be repeated today
super excited it's gonna be another fun
day for sure will be 16 players entered
this field we no longer have all 16
unfortunately some had to pack their
bags and go home because they were not
just eliminated once it's a double
elimination format so they lost two
separate matches they're done from this
field but we still have some great
contestants remaining dania as we get
the two game matches 10 plus two time
patrol and then the bidding armageddon
system which we saw yesterday that was a
lot of fun but done as you look at the
remaining bracket here of course
up top we have hikaru nakamura yan
napashi that is a matchup of monsters
and then in the losers bracket it gets
no easier when you see parham magsudu he
bukesh with the black pieces today he
takes on dingley wren now online and
then dimitri andreikin versus five yard
of karwana that's another slugfest so
take me through these matchups it's an
absolute meat grinder and parham xulu
his reward for beating ukesh you're
playing world champion challenger but
gukesh is one of those players
you know we know him so well when he
gets confident confident when he starts
bopping his head to real or imaginary
music during the game he's a really
scary opponent because of how fast he
plays and the pressure that he puts so
dingly wren we hope his connection is
stable today and it you know what
happens on the board is also going to be
a difficult challenge for him on drake
and caruana we were talking before the
show that's a 50 50 matchup both of
these players are absolute monsters
demetrion draken is still going to have
a chip on his shoulder after what
happened the first day can't wait to
jump into the loser's bracket and i
think people underestimate dimitri on
draken because they know that name
fabiano caruana like no he's gotta be
the favorite dimitri andre kin he got
second place in the rapid chess
championship in terms of grand prix
points he's an absolute beast in title
tuesdays so people somehow sleep on the
guy even though he's winning events left
and right i don't understand the
undraken effect and he's 27 20. you know
his feed is over 2700 too let's not
forget that either madrian draken is an
incredibly well-rounded player he's got
the exact skill set you need for
sustained success in rapid chess and he
is still in the running for that
incredibly sweet 30 000
first place prize that's a lot of cars
depends what cars you're buying but
those prizes are mouth-watering and for
the players still in the tournament
you know whether it's pride whether it's
the chip on their shoulder after the
initial loss or whether it's this
incredibly generous set of prizes
they're going to be as motivated as ever
today robert and the players who lose in
the start of the day in the losers
bracket round three they'll still go
home with 7 500 so it's going to be a
good payday no matter where you finish
of course they all want that grand prize
of 30 thousand dollars and none of this
will be possible without our presenting
sponsor coinbase so let's leave the
danny wrench to thank them as we get
ready for the day's action
the rapid chess championship is brought
to you by coinbase whether you're
looking to make your first crypto
purchase or you're an experienced trader
coinbase has you covered you can earn
crypto by learning about crypto at
coinbase.com explore d5 and web 3 with
your coinbase wallet get exclusive
rewards when you spend with your
coinbase card and much much more learn
more at coinbase.com chess and get 10 in
bitcoin when you sign up and verify your
account check them out use the command
sponsor or command coinbase today and go
to coinbase.com to get that bitcoin baby
once again thank you to coinbase for
sponsoring this great event and we're
not even done we're only halfway done
because we have today and tomorrow left
in this double elimination format but
it's time to present one of our players
to you with our hired player resume and
it's someone we have just been talking
about right it's somebody who's a bit
overlooked in the uh tournament circuit
despite the fact that he's well over 2
700 and has been for many years he was a
semi-final not stephen a second place
finisher runner-up at the world cup he's
a two-time russian champion this is
dimitri on draken so donya he can also
apparently walk on water
is that is that an actual thing are
there is that a talent that some people
have and other people don't have
well where this comes from is he was
doing an interview and he was more or
less saying that he was going to walk on
the beach during the rest day and he was
like oh i'm going to take a walk on the
water literally meant on the beach yeah
but he said he's going to walk on water
so hey you know he says he can do it why
not believe him uh but we want to also
give a shout out to hired uh you know
they're great helping us out here and if
you're tired of cover letters
applications and hidden salary ranges in
tech hire empower software engineers to
manage their own hiring path with a
marketplace of over 10 000 employers
worldwide higher candidates experienced
managers will help you navigate incoming
employer interview requests giving you
back the control to land a tech job
you'll love what's not to love create
your free hired profile today and well
get involved and get involved in the
chat right now because the hype is real
we do not have many players remaining
left half the field remains some in the
winner's bracket they're winning streak
unscathed they are hikara nakamura and
yon napomshi but we're getting set for
the players harham maksudlu who had a
big victory over the board in the
turkish league over bukesh with the
black pieces and dingley ren who as long
as he has a stable internet connection
donya i mean he's going to hang in there
with the best of them especially after
yesterday's match against notre back i
mean he took us through his entire skill
set that first game was think i'm
allowed to stay sexy in special
occasions that was that game wasn't sexy
and i don't know what is and then in the
second game against notre back
incredible resilience finding an only
move in a critically difficult position
to save and turn that game around so
parham
like we said he's gonna have to bring
his a game he did that this morning
against gookash he needs a little bit
more where that came from i like what
you said about him though he's a very
streaky player where sometimes he can
just win six games in a row and he's
gonna need that confidence that he's
been building we see him already bopping
his head a bit so we know he loves rap
music he loves the nba and if he's
listening that music and he can get his
pieces in the groove he could take down
dingley wren he absolutely could and i'm
excited to see what openings we are
going to see today we've seen a lot of
amazing preparation we've seen roy lopez
as we've seen catalans and queens gambit
declined one great thing about rapid
events is that you know whatever opening
you love whatever floats your boat
you're gonna see a little bit of that
because the players roll out their
entire repertoire can't wait to jump
into this two-game match
and uh ding's gonna have to keep up on
the clock and let's not forget that
dingley ren has a style somewhat similar
to the position that duval had with the
white pieces against parham yesterday
and parham not just survived that he won
that game which was surprising he saw
the tactics better than doubt did so
dingly wren he had some trouble against
jose martinez he faces a player similar
in style a stronger player than jose
with all respect meant towards the
peruvian grandmaster but parham he is
now
25 feeding and classical
yeah i know he is he's finding his form
we know that the talent was there he's
putting it all together and he's a
well-rounded versatile player himself so
dingler and better be careful
27 25
and i was looking argent guy sees 27 15
there's a complete takeover of top level
chess by these young players it's
unbelievable the success that they're
experiencing over the board and that's
just making them more confident that's
making them a nightmare pairing in these
online events where they have nothing to
lose
right no i mean parham he's the underdog
if you had a vote here who would make it
through this match i'm pretty sure
people are saying dingley wren so parham
knows that he's got two games he gets
the black pieces and the white pieces
and dingly wren
when his internet is stable we know how
good he is let's not forget when he
lost by disconnection in game one
against in round one game one against
jeffrey zhang he was completely winning
and he would have won with the black
pieces and then with the white pieces
good luck beating dingley wren unless
it's not one of the candidates or
against teamwork of but yeah like it's
just not gonna happen so we see the
first moves are underway here between
ding and parham and we have a
symmetrical english
and ding sticking to his guns he's been
playing the english pretty religiously
online over the board taking a little
bit of time maybe not expecting a
symmetrical english and an early bishop
fianchetto we're gonna get a symmetrical
structure here most likely
yeah look at this we have oh an a6
yeah that's catching me a bit off garb
and it's clear that sure he's setting up
for some kind of rook b8 b5 maneuver uh
but you typically don't see that that
early and i would play e3 and d4 very
quickly for one he hasn't brushed his
teeth yet he's already preparing b5
and he follows through on it i mean who
needs to develop their king side who
needs to castle that's that's what the
old generation does the cool kids they
play on the queen side in the open
and i wonder donya if dingley wren doing
the principled approach with castle
kingside if he would have been better
off starting with e3 and d4 because if
your opponent is playing on the flank
you should probably strike in the center
he could still do just that but b5 is
coming very quickly and so he needs to
deal with that and he goes a4 to stop it
all together
and of course the obvious positional
downside of the move a4 is that you are
creating a hole on b4 now black's not
going to rush to put a knife there right
if black puts an item before
congratulations what is it doing there
but that's a long-term weakness and uh
it's probably worth the investment that
parham put in he spent two tempe on a6
in rook b8 and what he got in return is
a potential
outpost for his knight
and parham with the full 10 minutes and
dingley wren he's moving methodically
i'm going to give him credit for that
you know he doesn't really uh rush his
decisions and that's why he's able to
win long grind them out end games like
he did in the candidates over yanchez of
duda and nikara nakamura in the last
game but when you're playing a 10 minute
plus two second increment rapid game
dania it feels like maybe he's taking a
little bit too much time in the early
stages are you do you think that he's
right at home
one minute for ten moves i think he's
fine
i think you know parham is such a fast
player that uh with certain players you
cannot
measure your time expenditure based on
what your opponent is doing uh and
parham is a good example of that
dinglerang just needs to keep himself
you know over five minutes as they enter
the middle game and he's the one who has
to make a bunch of decisions here
another decision he has to decide
whether to play d5 and get into kind of
a king's indian fiance type of vibe or
do you keep the tension in the center
probably he won't take on c5
you know i'm very happy if i'm parham in
that case
i think parham has done a great job here
the weakness of the square robert
and the fact that the move b3 weakens
the long diagonal i think parham is
pretty happy here yeah he should be and
if ding is not careful bishop g4 will
soften up the d4 square so you would
want to leave the tension if you're
dingly ren but it's not entirely clear
how you should do that i think b3 is an
okay move but you better follow it up
accurately because opening up the
diagonal as you mentioned dania that
could be a big problem but at the same
time where else is that dark square
bishop going for ding i think it should
go to a3
yeah it probably should to put pressure
on the c5 pawn and in response to the
move d5
i'm i was trying to figure out where
parham wants to put his knight because
in the king's indian you normally go to
a5 but here he has additional access to
the b4 square but ding
not uh you know that doesn't float his
boat he does go b3
and bishop g4 looks like a natural
continuation here trying to put more
pressure on the d4 pawn and induce the
move d5
yeah bishop g4 looks very logical but
there is a clear downside because if you
are not quick in the center
then you're giving up the bishop pair
perhaps for nothing so bishop g4 h3 chop
chop on f3 like if you're not quickly
getting to the d4 pawn then you just
handed white this really lovely light
square bishop yeah you might get into a
situation like this and all of a sudden
yeah wait a second why do we give away
all the light squares there's some cool
tactics
uh that arise if white plays d5 after
bishop g4 i think that runs into knight
takes d5
and after a cd bishop takes c3 the rook
is attacked and white can't even get two
pieces for it so that's out of the
question
and parham e7 e5 wow not every day you
see a move like this in this type of
position no but it does make sense and
it has some spanish vibes to it right
where you move the knight to a5 and then
play c5 you could just do this in one
turn but donna the big downside of
making this move is that white will have
a pawn controlling d4 black will not
have a pawn controlling d5 so oftentimes
when you see pawns two squares away like
c5 and e5 you look at the square in
between and maybe white can take control
of that
yeah so dc makes a lot of sense maybe
parham wants
maybe he's flirting with a some sort of
intermediate move such as e4
but then you run the risk of losing that
pawn right
so
i like it i like the creative this is
parham style this is him at his best and
he's not afraid to make moves like this
when he's being provocative
and he's forcing ding to spend loads of
time here i mentioned ding wants to stay
over five minutes as they're entering
the middle game they're on move 10
robert he already has six minutes i
don't like where ding's clock is going
here
yeah this is i was kind of hinting at
this before parham he makes everybody
seem slow by comparison because he is
just so quick in the opening stage and
he's feeling it he won a game with black
against goo cash today over the board
classical chess and an important game in
the turkish league and now he's doing
exactly what we said he might bopping
that head around he's feeling the music
he absolutely is and he's feeling the
music of this position as he puts more
pressure on ding's pawn forces ding to
make a serious decision here i mean the
move d5 i think is the most conservative
approach but with that close center
black has the stock plan of preparing b7
b5 and if you get that move in you've
got like a king's indian dream
no you definitely do because that rook
on b8 it doesn't just want to sit on
that square it wants to push that b5
pawn and open up the file in front of it
so uh this is a big moment here for ding
i think he should just chop one of the
pawns play bishop a3 and get his
development done with
and he should do that sooner rather than
later bishop a3
now knight before is not possible on
account of knight takes c5 so
you know parham's position is not all
peaches and cherries i mean he's going
to have to make some weaknesses of his
own and you pointed out the light
squares in the center are what i think
white should hang his hat on and if you
play b6 the last thing i'll say is that
you always have to watch out about the
move a4 a5 if you can get this knight
off of c6 a5 can introduce serious
weaknesses in black's queen side
structure
that's right and i think that the one
thing that ding is really considering
right now is if d takes c5 and he plays
the move d5 it might have been your e4
pawn push so instead he plays d5
attacking this knight on c6 and black
can still play e4 here so ding was doing
the right thing by spending all this
time because e4 things get really
tactical quickly that knight on each c3
is loose behind it the rook on a1 might
be hanging the bishop g7 is thrilled to
see the open diagonal so this is messy
yeah
i think after e4 white is probably best
advice to take tonight but parham he
refrains from the tactics night before
quickly
and now
the the two plans and you can combine
them first of all we talked about bishop
d7 and b5 second of all you resort to
the king's indian idea of moving the
knight away and pushing the fbi you will
never guess that this position did not
actually come from a king's indian
symmetrical english you kidding me
[Laughter]
hi everyone i'm sorry but we're
experiencing some technical difficulties
here in the studio i hope you'll be
patient with us as we get things in
order before we return back to the
broadcast this video will now play on
loop
hi everyone we're experiencing some
technical difficulties here in the
studio i hope you'll be patient with us
as we get things in order in order for
the broadcast to return this video will
now play on loop
hi everyone
we're experiencing some technical
difficulties here in the broadcast
i hope you'll be patient with us as we
work hard to get it back this video will
now play on loop
hi everyone
we're experiencing some technical
difficulties here on the broadcast
i hope that we can get things in order
soon this video will now play on loop
hi everyone
i'm sorry but we're experiencing some
technical difficulties on the broadcast
right now i hope you'll be patient with
us as we get things in order this video
will now play on luke
hi everyone we're experiencing some
technical difficulties here on the
broadcast
i hope you'll be patient with us as we
get things in order
this video will now play on
hi everyone
we're experiencing some technical
difficulties on the broadcast right now
i hope you'll stick with us and be
patient as we work to return this video
will now play on loop
hi everyone we're experiencing some
technical difficulties on the broadcast
right now
i hope you'll be patient with us as we
get things in order
this video will now play on loop
hi everyone
we're experiencing some technical
difficulties on the broadcast right now
i hope you'll be patient with us as we
work hard to get things in order this
video will now play on loop
hi everyone
we're experiencing some technical
difficulties on the broadcast right now
i hope you'll be patient with us as we
work hard to get this back in order this
video will now play on loop
hi everyone
we're experiencing some technical
difficulties on the broadcast right now
i hope you'll be patient with us as we
work hard to get things in order
this video will now play on loop
hi everyone
we're experiencing some technical
difficulties on the broadcast right now
i hope you'll be patient with us as we
work to get things in order
this video will now play on loop
hi everyone
we're experiencing some technical
difficulties on the broadcast right now
i hope you'll be patient with us as we
work hard to get things in order this
video will now play on loop
hi everyone i'm sorry but we're
experiencing some technical difficulties
here in the studio i hope you'll be
patient with us as we get things in
order before we return back to the
broadcast this video will now play on
loop
hi everyone we're experiencing some
technical difficulties here in the
studio i hope you'll be patient with us
as we get things in order in order for
the broadcast to return this vid
hi everyone i'm sorry but we're
experiencing some technical difficulties
here in the studio i hope you'll be
patient with us as we get things in
order before we return back to the
broadcast this video will now play on
loop
hi everyone we're experiencing some
technical difficulties here in the
studio i hope you'll be patient with us
as we get things in order in order for
the broadcast to return this video will
now play on loop
hi
everyone we're experiencing some
technical difficulties here in the
broadcast
i hope you'll be patient with us as we
work hard to get it back this video will
now play on loop
hi everyone
we're experiencing some technical
difficulties here on the broadcast
i hope that we can get things in order
soon this video will now play on loop
first off instead white is on the verge
of being able to play e5 parham has to
stop that robert because if e5 comes in
favorable conditions for white this
could end up being losing in two seconds
well speaking of losing in two seconds
we have to go to the other game because
it wasn't that exciting before but now
all of a sudden dimitri on draken
completely winning against fabiano
caruana whoa whoa whoa whoa
is he up a piece or am i miss counting
no you're counting correctly and he's
about to be up two pieces he's gonna
play f5 and slam through on the king
side
holy cannoli i mean this happened in a
hurry because if you go back just to
move 16 quickly that this knight uh
after knight f6 for black the knight
went to h4 and all of a sudden there was
the threat of knight f5 and pawn f4 and
fabinho could not find a good way to
deal with both those threats just
storming the barricades this is a
classic idea you have two pawns
attacking e5
forced fabia's force to take and there's
a forkovich
now black technically robert has three
pawns for the piece but that's a moot
point because on top of the extra piece
white has a devastating kingside
initiative f5 here and i think black can
essentially resign yeah the bishop on g4
is loose in addition to white trying to
pry open the king's head because you if
you played g5 and the knight moved back
maybe black would have some chances but
unfortunately the bishop is just hanging
on g4 that's the second minor piece
you're dropping of course against
dimitri on drake and you have no chance
you have a spike check on c5 doesn't do
anything the move bishop h3 runs into f
takes g6
and i mean black's king is gonna get put
through the meat grinder an unfortunate
start for fabiano caruana because
defeating dimitri on draken on demand
jeffrey zhang managed that yesterday
but
his task is going to be cut out for him
he's going to have to pull another
alexis serrano
yes and we were talking about demetrion
draken right we were saying that somehow
he's underestimated and yet here he
comes he is just going for fabiano caron
he's not scared of anybody on this
planet and he is showing that right now
and it looks like one of the players
might have dropped off camera i think
that was fabiano so uh hopefully he gets
reconnected although maybe he just wants
to disconnect from this game lose on
time he's looking for his minor piece
he's looking for
where did my knight go
well we'll go back to the other game
since this one is
over but the one between dingley ren and
parham also is about to be over look at
that past pawn on d5 it's even material
here but that's like a plus four and
change evaluation because it's a clear
pass pawn the bishop on h5 watch out for
that though daniel i think that this is
where viewers can be misled when they
say it's obviously winning for white but
if you're not careful and you allow that
bishop to d1
at the wrong moment all of a sudden
black can get counter play
yeah black's gonna make shawarma out of
these pawns
and uh for that reason ding has to
operate very precisely on the
uh on the queen side
precise ending those two words usually
don't go in the same sentence but
somehow here they are and parham won
last attempt he opens the g5 but he's a
day late and uh shall i say a turkish
lira short
nice one there and yeah he is just not
getting things going quickly enough on
the king side uh white can take on g5 he
says nah whatever take on f4 have my
pawn and he gets his king out of the pin
that's the most important thing as long
as he's not dropping his bishop there
there are no infiltration scores rook g3
that does go after the b3 pawn but the
problem is that white's pawns are going
to be too quick and
you just go yeah here they come
yeah and if you play rook d g6 i think
actually bishop h1
no bishop h1 then maybe rook g3 this
gets a little bit dicey so i guess
bishop f3 trading the bishops is a
better call
and uh better call saul because white's
about to destroy the both f pawns and
then promote the past c and d pawns but
that's actually really important because
i think many people would retreat their
bishop to h1 being like my king is safer
when the g2 square is covered but as
you're pointing out rook g3 takes h3
rook h2 check coming all of a sudden
white could just lose this game
you can never fall asleep in the end
game you don't need a lot of pieces to
checkmate the king
and uh
ding would definitely have played bishop
f3 but an instructive moment indeed
barham going for the first stop this is
surgical precision look at this rookie
seven rook c6
he's about to promote the pawn
and he's left parham in the dust here
dr ding he's being clinical right now
and this is whatever yeah no look at
this he's just getting a past pawn on c6
that can't be chased down so uh very
nicely done here by dingley wren his
connection holding up and it's what we
said the whole time that if his
connection holds up he can beat anybody
in this field he is not afraid of hikaru
nakamura he took hikaru to the bitter
end of the speed chess championship and
in even quicker time controls that is
hikaru's forte so dingley red proving
that he's not just the number two in the
world in classical chess but in online
chess and speed chess he can handle
himself quite nicely i mean he just
disassembled parham in this middle game
good preparation that rook b8 a6 id i
think it works out pretty well but
parham underestimating the speed of
ding's kingside initiative
and here come the pawns d5 d6
i guess barham will try rook d3 here but
then you can just push that pawn up to
d7 if you want
yep here comes the pawn well i'm about
to sneeze
i held it i held it that was about i was
about to sneeze and somehow i held it in
but uh
i think the bishop is going to come in
handy right here with bishop d5 closing
down the rook on d3 from chasing down
that pawn uh so i think that uh this one
is looking pretty clear though you do
watch out because rook d2 check actually
i know
king doesn't have too many escape
squares yeah rookie two followed by f3
and suddenly black is the one being the
aggressor
and bishop d5 is on the board oh rook d2
check i think king f1 is very important
to be able to block the first string
check with the move rookie one that's
huge because actually we can just show
rook d2 king e1 that just makes a draw
because rook d1 and back to d2 so you
have to put that king on f1 so you can
block the check and then your d-pawn
will run yeah finally you're ready for
d7 the white bishop doing a great job of
both defending the rook and cutting off
black's king not allowing it to move
back to f7 which which would be
a last resort for stopping the pawn but
this
sort of um geometry of pieces pawn on f4
bishop h5 and the rook that's such a
clever way of trying to make a draw
because the king can't escape to the
third rank no matter what and with the
d1 square defended by the bishop you'll
always have these checks on d2 and d1 so
being able to block with the rook is so
essentially the only reason dingley ryan
is still winning the game of course he
mapped this out a while back
yeah i'm just focusing on all the
different colors that i can draw the
arrows
i like it you know doing a deep dive
into this position
i love the orange yes no i think uh you
were pretty much the next i don't even
know what i wouldn't say picasso but
that's not anything like a picasso that
was more maybe who is known for their
use of colors i don't know i'll give you
a i'll give you a pollock you're just
throwing colors out and then them land
on the canvas
you're so cultured did you just come
back from the moma or something no i
didn't but now i kind of want to go to
to the met actually
that's right well both of them are you
know
fine establishments here in new york
i mean you should go to charlotte
definitely outdoes manhattan in terms of
the quality of museums
uh you know i would believe you except
you're
just making things up
yeah thank you thank you for believing
me so this one's over should we whoa now
the other game still isn't over yeah i
think there's been some complications
look at this now this is completely
winning still but fabi has clearly done
a great job of at least
dragging dimitri's clock down and making
it a little bit more interesting yeah
this is surprising the game is
continuing fabiano now is left thinking
how do i defend my king he does bring
his bishop back because if he brought
his king up to g7 there's bishop takes
h6 check distracting the king from the
rook so bishop oh
and critically after c2 you don't go
back to f1 because then there's rick d1
it's actually checkmate rookie six and
rook out five
is mate in two so
that's the important detail both games
right now we have attacks late in the
end game the difference being here
white's attack actually is successful
and i think fabi is losing
a second minor piece on f8
yeah this one's just done at this point
because c2 the pawn is not uh promoting
soon enough and he just goes
king to h oh wait a second bishop yeah
but
then rookie one and rook d1 bishop a3 oh
that's so important it looks like that
yeah this is really important because
after c2 you couldn't initially bring
your bishop to a3 but only after the
rook moves away to d1 does the bishop of
axis there but that's enough it stops
the pawn that's winning
that said then you bring your knight
back around to e3 and dimitri is going
to see that bishop takes f8 is on the
board
and i think fabio will likely resign
either here or after bishop a3
yeah here it comes
bishop a3 only move and you can see how
narrow the margin of victory is when you
play against guys like fabi and after c5
i think bishop e7 is the only move or
king a king h6 right like they you're
kind of doing this very close i guess
king e2 should win and that might be the
easiest but uh it's close d8
look at how much fabi is capable of
producing with a single rook on the
board
that's like when hicaro has only a king
left as dimitri
you know goes for the executive decision
gives the bishop up for a couple of
pawns but hicaro is a king left and he
produces more counter play than some
people with an entire army that's true
and demetrion draken he was a man on a
mission he scores the victory as did
dingley wren so the players with the
white pieces they use the first move to
their advantage they lead that is
dingley wren one nil over para maksoudlu
and dimitron draken one nil over fabiona
caruana so
yesterday we saw fabiano being very
adventurous in the opening when he
needed to win i wonder what he's going
to cook up with the white pieces against
andre who is as solid as players get
well i'm expecting one e4 that's a
pretty dependable way to produce winning
chances now dimitri in his repertoire
he's got the sicilian but my guess is
he's going to orient himself toward a
berlin and something tells me fabi is
not exactly going to go into the end
game
i don't know why i'm thinking that i'm
just it's just conjecture
i i think that there are certain times
you go for that especially because most
people avoid the berlin end game so
going into it can really test your
opponents like not just knowledge in
terms of memorized preparation but
understanding because if you haven't
looked at something in a while you just
you can't rely on the memory bank you
have to come up with the moves over the
board so i i feel like it's not going to
happen i agree with you donya but you
know sometimes it's good to test your
opponent in those waters for sure it
reminds me of this game i played against
uh grand master sergio zarov who should
be a familiar name uh also played in the
rcc a couple times uh we were playing a
couple years ago now i've never played
the berlin game in my life but as i'm
preparing for the game i'm noticing that
against the move knight f6 he always
plays d3 right he doesn't go into the
end game so in in my infinite genius i
decide that i don't know the play he's
never going to go for the end game guess
what he does of course he castles knight
takes c4 he plays d4 he goes into the
end game i have no idea what i'm doing
i've never looked at it from black's
perspective i somehow pulled out a draw
but i was so red
i was read as a tomato when he took on
e5 and so yeah
it's like who's the fool now right like
you say oh i got you you didn't expect
me to do this
fortunately he also wasn't too big of a
specialist but i think he sensed that
i'm not a berlin endgame player right
and that's the thing right why did donya
play this against me he doesn't play it
at all arizke trading queens this early
that's tough about this let's take him
to the end game but it's true so i
wonder what fabiano will play i could
see him playing one of his like d4 and
then like his catalan type of positions
but andreikin he's just
he's so solid right like we know him
very well from playing him and just
commenting on many of his games and
studying his chess but i just feel like
as we've been saying to the beginning of
the show he's just so underestimated not
by caruana i mean fabiano of course
knows dimitri respects him but from the
general chess public
yeah i mean he doesn't get too high or
the highest doesn't get too low with the
lows and it's not like when you think of
dimitri you can point to you know one
particular brilliancy that he played oh
this is the game where he became famous
he's just known for his consistency
consistently good tournament
performances over the board and he's
been good for for such a long time he's
only in his early 30s but he's been over
2 700 probably for over a decade now
that level of experience is not to be
taken for granted and the second pair of
games kick off parham similarly in a
very difficult must-win spot and goes
for the fried lover that's not a bad
choice in my opinion if you want to
guarantee
uh an imbalance and winning chances
yes no i think it's a
good good try there so maybe um
[Music]
for the moment we can focus on that game
the other board seems to still be on the
previous game between
draken and carwana so let's uh head on
over to
uh whichever game you want i mean i
think this param game we have to go to
yeah yeah we and h4 is on the board and
i'm pretty sure i've seen that before i
don't think this is some sort of crazy
novelty
but it has got ding thinking what do you
know about this
well
these type of lines are very complicated
because if we go to uh the board between
dingley ren and parham muksudlu
h4 is played so white is up a pawn
that's obvious uh if we just count the
material but what black usually gets in
these positions is a quick f5 so even if
white tries to stop the move f5 i mean
how actually do you do you're gonna play
g4 that's right way too much uh so there
is an easy way let's say it's like queen
f3 thinking you're going to stop f5 i'm
pretty sure black can still play f5
black because
if you take f8 yeah you're walking into
rook f8 and well you're going to lose
that bishop on f5
right because g6 is coming next if white
defends it with g4 this is very
unappetizing and so what often often
happens in these lines is white allows
f5 and e4 and then you have to very
carefully
navigate your way around the pawns
typical idea is to move this bishop away
from d3 and then try to break through
the pawn chain with the move d3 so black
has to play
with tremendous activity and you need a
good sense of the initiative if you want
to handle this position with black and
you look at these queen side pieces for
white the rook gun a1 the bishop on c1
in particular it takes development why
you know quite a while for them to get
out the knight of course can go to c3 at
any moment but the bishop on scene one's
not getting out the rook on a1 is stuck
there and that knight on d5 at any
moment can go to f4 now you don't have
to move the knight right we tend to
think trading pieces is bad when we're
down material but let's think what we
gain knight takes d5 c takes d5 would be
the response for black now we have an
even more menacing center when our f5
pawn comes up as well so i think that
these positions are very difficult for
white to play and so ding look at him he
doesn't move his knight he plays h6 just
kicking that knight back and he'll play
f5 when he wants to go castle and i like
the choice from parham because he needs
a win but i think that dingley wren he
knows what he's doing and he's not going
to shy away from the complications and
the presence of the pawn on h4 makes it
a lot more difficult for white to castle
kingside that now comes with a very
hefty price tag you've created a gaping
hole on g4 if black sticks his bishop
there and then brings the knight to f4
you can get steamrolled so quickly here
and look at ding castling he doesn't
care about the e5 farm here come take it
open up the e file for me after rookie 8
you're gonna have to castle here then
the bishop comes out to d6 the other
bishop comes out to g4 this is exactly
what you want to avoid in a fried liver
nobody cares that you're up two pawns
after knight takes e66 you're up three
pawns doesn't make your position any
better no no no the h4 pawn is loose
yeah the downside of pushing pawns where
your king eventually goes nah this is
just a disaster so and look at the if we
um i'll compare this game with the game
between five men of caruana and
demetrion draken uh it's it's funny how
when you say you need to win a game what
are you gonna do people take drastically
different approaches so
in the other game if we're able to
switch on over there
we see that carwana he is taking a more
positional approach but i actually
really like his position i mean he has
more space with the white pieces he just
went pawn a4 threatening pawn a5 to trap
this bishop on b6 and
danya it's it's slight but it's very
fabiano first of all i'm going to give
myself a little pat on the back guess
what opening this game from berlin and
bobby playing d3 the anti berlin yeah
they don't call me a prophet for nothing
but no this is as good of a position as
you get from the d3 anti-berlin
i mean white's got all of the assets
that he could possibly ask for there's
pressure on e5 he's threatening to trap
the bishop and this is a very unpleasant
situation because if dimitri plays the
normal move a6 then you're gonna have to
reckon with knight takes b6 when your
queen side pawn structure is permanently
ruined this is not what he signed up for
when he played one of the most
dependable openings in all of chess not
this
but he's gonna have to go through
something like this and he plays c6
now after knight takes b6 the queen side
pawn structure is a little bit more
intact i think that's a good decision by
dima it is and now if i should go for a
different plan he should play with a5
just to kick the bishop off of the
diagonal and then when bishop goes to c7
trade on e5 and you can even trade
queens and then play bishop to e3 and
the point is look at the bishop on c7
it's now a passive bystander here while
the bishop on e3 is very strong white's
plan becomes clear you're putting a rook
on d1 as you're showing and
look at black you're tied down to the e5
pawn white is very active here and i
think this is where players make
mistakes they think oh trading queens i
can't win a position like that and
fabiano actually took on e5 right away
so he's probably just changing the move
order uh by one but the point is that he
has a clear advantage now with much more
activity
and dimitri deciding to take with a
knight
okay okay now you could still take on d7
and play a5 just because there's one
less pair of minor pieces does not
diminish i think the effectiveness of
this approach and that is exactly what
fabi is going for you called it except
he starts with the move b4
so he's inviting oh no a5 doesn't work
because of rook d1 right so he's
inviting a blunder yeah he's fighting
draken
for some reason does not blunder
surprisingly
yeah no i think i don't know
i like this for white i i'm not saying
it's winning it's far from that of
course but i feel like what's black's
plan where white has
removed like a5 or rook d1 to play it
feels like a very
safe risk-free approach where dimitri is
gonna struggle to defend uh accurately
and if you look at the clocks fabiano
playing very quickly and confidently and
now losing connection
and now losing connection and he's got
an infinite supply of these improving
moves and the big question for dimitri
eventually he's going to have to do
something with this a7 because at some
point you'll need the services of your
a8 rook but if you play the move a6 and
that's the problem with these kinds of
positions every move contains a super
unappetizing drawback if you play a6 you
weaken the b6 pawn if you play b6 and
try to erect a barricade then you're
walking into a5 and the situation is
exacerbated so
you know extreme precision is going to
be required for dimitri here if he wants
to save this end game and by the way i
love that you suggested e1 to d1 because
that's i believe the correct rook to
move the rook at e1 is not doing
anything we tend to think our rooks
belong to the center but no the rook on
a1 is well positioned as you're pointing
out if black is to push one of these
pawns on the queen side whether it's the
a pawn or the b5 for black the rook on
a1 is actually important so he goes rook
e to b1 which apparently is a mistake
i was concerned about the possibility of
black wing b7 b5 but
i don't think that that's necessarily it
white can take and play knight a5
what what do you think it is i mean the
engine suggests that white's advantage
is fully evaporated after this move now
i will say the danger is that black
might stick a rook on t3 and i think
that might be connected to why rook b1
is a mistake according to the engine is
it knight f6
it might just be knight f6 that looks
incredibly reasonable straight forward
and rook t3
on b5 is now a huge threat
oh and so is rook takes c3
right it's a double attack
it's a flat out double attack i think
dimitri believed him though look at that
he went king f8 he said
okay i'm just going to bring my king to
the center it's the end game that's the
principled approach but that gives
fabiano uh the correct amount of time
where he can play b5 himself as white
and then he's threatened to open up the
b file and land a rook on b7 or he can
sort of correct by playing f3 or rook to
d1 something like that i mean the
advantage is going to last so i think
that maybe we can uh you know trust
fabiano to press for a while and trust
on draken to do his best to put up
sturdy defense let's go back to the
other game just because i see that
parham's king
is sitting there on f1
and his material advantage is still at
i'm still counting it's at two pawns
but black's compensation is so visually
apparent here yeah you know i think we
should frame it this way danya that uh
white has comp two pawns of compensation
for his lack of development
yeah
it's the other way around
yeah no this is this is overwhelming i
mean the other rooks coming to e8 the
sad thing is that if white plays bishop
d3
the rook doesn't even have to move from
e4 because of that darn bishop on g4 how
is parham
going to untangle the knight on a5 is
just salivating at the prospect of
dropping in for a visit on c4
black's got everything you could ask for
from a fried liver and if parham is down
90 seconds on the clock it's the same
with nepo if nepo's down on the clock a
pretty dependable sign that he's deeply
uncomfortable with his position b3 on
the board and the evolver hated it
and dingley wren i mean he is a
pre-movie at this point like rook a to
e8 another bishop comes to e3 so this is
the moment where you need to play
accurately for black because it looks
very promising the white king on f1 is
never going to be safe and as you point
out bishop f4 to my eyes looks like a
fantastic move and
oh
not according to the evil bars eyes yeah
but i wonder why maybe it's just
maybe just takes
wow oh and if rook takes c2 which i was
hoping for why does bishop e5
intercepting the rooks well that's
clutch that's actually one of those
really clutch moves that you
can rely on to survive so he went knight
c6 and c3 now and my eyes are looking at
bishop f4 i'm also thinking about the
exchange sack rook takes e3 i don't know
if it lands me enough but it does feel
like one of those positions where you
just start throwing everything in fact
like what rajabov did to dingley wren
no this looks this is completely winning
actually i mean look at the dark squares
c3 is falling
you know if black was down a rook here
rather than exchange the position to be
unclear right but with all of the
services of the minor pieces this is
just look at this i mean white cannot
move queen d2 bishop f4 sending the
queen back the king has no safe haven
the knight's coming into g3
i think ding's going for this
yes and
you know parham he needed to play
something risky adventurous to have any
hope of defeating the ultra solid
dingley wren but that's the thing about
dingley wren people think oh he's just
this positional mastermind he'll squeeze
you and he doesn't want any tactics he's
fine in tactical positions right he
actually enjoys them quite a lot and his
candidates in 2016 he had this crazy
game against alexander grishik i
remember that where they're like just
throwing all the pieces at each other so
you don't get the 2800 by accident you
don't get the 2800 by only playing one
style he is versatile and he is an
unbelievable player so he's doing really
well right now against bar home
that's a great point and it really flies
in the face of you know a lot of people
who like to label players and say well
this guy doesn't like these types of
positions like you're saying everybody
has a universal style dingley wren knows
how to sacrifice pieces trust us yes by
the way um on the other board while
dingley run is calculating his decision
here on the other one look at what
fabiano caruana is doing to demetria and
dragon this is on draken's worst
nightmare because fabiano sort of
accomplished everything he could
possibly dream of
oh my goodness he's got the a file the
bishop is worse than it's ever been
the d5 square the d4 square is protected
yes i don't this is ugly to look at and
the big problem for black like looking
at this is knight takes b6 would be the
move to try to solve your problems if
white takes on b6 well you you of course
are seeing the correct knight but it
should hit the play yeah right but if
white takes on b6 with the knight you'll
see the evaluation going down quite a
lot because yes black's bishop is
passive but white doesn't really have an
easy way to take advantage of that
passivity there's no
nothing to attack or attack with but the
problem is you were highlighting was
rook takes a7 give me that pawn your
bishop is loose on c7
and on top of that the rook is rampaging
through the ranks you have a past people
on that's out of the question so dimitri
taking the pawn oh this is getting worse
and worse and worse
pushed to the last just the last couple
of squares fabie just needs to find that
last finishing blow
and which can be hard which can be hard
very true but you know how we talk about
pawns two squares apart like c5 and e5
white has this d5 square to use at some
point to be a turn style and white's
pawn structure is actually quite nice
because when this knight goes to e6
sorry it's not fair yeah where exactly
are you going the answer is absolutely
nowhere
look at this
the white pawns it's like it's like when
they used to bury vampires and lights
but put spikes around the grave mm-hmm
you know so that the vampire would get
impaled when he rose that's like that
knight on e6 account dracula
transylvania is closed
yeah no this is uh
this is brutal right now because
like why can't just push like h4 push
some pawns there as you're indicating
move the bishop play knight e3 knight d5
the problem though is when you're left
with too many appealing options you kind
of just choose one at random not fabinho
won't do that but sometimes players do
that and then they pick the wrong one
and the advantage just dissipates so uh
here fatherhood is expanding you think
knight on e6 you have precisely zero
places to go to at least not hopping
forward
yeah this is such a
you know russian schoolboy kind of move
but i think it's time to get down to
business you you really want your c4
knight to migrate to d5 and i think
moving the bishop out of the way makes a
lot of sense here bishop d2
or you could continue being patient but
there goes fabi
yeah what does black even do here right
like rook d7 okay what do you do like
bishop d8 next you can't even do that
your e5 pawn is loose well if white
plays 93 then you can play bishop d8
right and i think that's what he's
preparing for
okay but after bishop dia can you just
even trade rooks put your next work on
a7
hey i hate blacksmith as much as the
next guy over i'm no staunch defender of
what dmitry's doing here it was funny
because you're like dude why are you
coming at me like that i'm not playing
game position either the problem for
i don't this
black is every single white's pieces is
better than blacks right like the rook
on b8 is worse than the rook on and a1
is about to land on a7 the bishop on d8
is terrible the knight on e6 is actually
okay but with the knight coming to d5
it's clear that white is the happy
happier player between the two
though i've seen enough dimitri games to
know that he can turn anything around
and he is not going to beat himself so
fabi he has to continue improving his
position and he's going to have to seize
the opportunity to deliver the crushing
blow when it arises
yeah this is uh
it just looks so bad especially because
on draken he's doing well on the clock
but with just three and a half minutes
i'm just i mean right now c4 for white
just
oh you can't take them and then i go
back to e6 but then the bishop drives
into c3 right it's like your knight goes
there i will take you because the knight
on a light square
is just i mean it's looking to the
heavens just you can't touch it
at some point later down the road white
could consider pushing the kingside
pawns
obviously you want to do that very very
carefully you don't want to create any
unnecessary weaknesses but if i were to
meet her i'd go 96
and then i'd play f6
and then i'd basically you know ask fabi
how are you actually beating me oh whoa
he takes d5
uh he takes d5 for 800 please
right
you know what's interesting donya as we
looked at the other game before and now
look at this one you would think that
fabiano was playing black against parham
and dingley wren is playing white
against on draken right like
stylistically this is a very dingly wren
like effort
yeah this is a great point but if we
quickly go back to the other game here
uh
i mean as much as parham probably
wouldn't want us to
oh my goodness look at this position
look at the rook and h1 it's
oh my gosh
talk about domination ding doesn't have
to do anything you can put a rook on e3
and go eat lunch
or dinner whatever
this is
one of the most horrific positions
parliament's probably ever seen he
doesn't want to look at this position he
knows he has to try but he's ready to
resign for sure no to win this i mean
knight takes d4 and i think he will
resign oh gosh then i can come to c2 and
just hop everywhere you can drive the
pawn into f4 if you want to tighten the
screws in even further you can still
play knight c2 still yeah exactly
in such positions it is impossible to
stop
the winning side from doing anything
whatever you want
even after knight takes b3 black is
probably winning
it might be seriously that's that's how
bad white's position also black it has
two minor pieces
for rook and that rook on h1 isn't
really a rook so yeah this is painful to
look at no this is over
ding is greatly enjoying himself trust
me
he's savoring every moment here you
don't get a position like this every day
against some of parham's caliber
no you don't and parham had a great day
over the board but his online day is not
being so friendly to him but you know he
had a great event he won two matches
yesterday against grishouk and dubois so
just to be here was a huge
accomplishment especially because game
one against grishok he was completely
lost in the end game if krishuk found
that one night move to win the game not
totally he
he can hold his head up by no question
about it no shame in losing to a world
champion challenger
right so why don't we go to the game
between um
fabiano and on draken just because that
one actually has a little bit more they
drew
they drew
that's a pity draw offer but it wins the
match so who cares
and you better take this dress as ding
okay here we go here's the other game
and
we have that pawn on d5 so last we
tracked dimitri had taken on d5
and finally pushing his kings i
mentioned that you've got to be very
careful when you do this did he choose
the wrong moment for the move f4
apparently
if so why is it because if he takes f4
and g5
that would be my first i mean okay so
we're biased by the eval bar like if i
was thinking about this right i'm
thinking what is black trying to
accomplish pushing those pawns at the
king side 100
uh maybe like slithering in with the
king okay well look dmitry doesn't have
the eval bar so he doesn't know
what mistakes are happening but white
cannot play f5 and the e4 pawn has to be
a goner and i think dimitri is
hanging his hat on the move g6
with the idea of course of connecting
the f and e pawn so there clearly is a
flaw with that
and i wonder what it is f5 g6
what is the crushing blum it takes in
bishop f4 or something yeah the king's
coming up to e3 anyway and
just domination
yeah it feels like some things
something's going to give even an
exchange stack on d8 it's not totally oh
you know where the okay you just came up
with a beautiful line for me thank you
fg
bishop f4 okay like f5 d6 whatever king
just move your king somewhere random
king h7 no h7 go to the a7 okay rook c8
king g6 rook c7
if you take pawn takes and you can't
stop me from promoting and the bishop on
f4 so pretty the way white's pieces are
arranged here
now one way or another something like
this is going to happen only thing that
worries me probably down to 36 seconds
he's got to move
he's got to stay over 15 seconds just
because anything can happen you see he
went to one bar of connection so that's
his biggest problem right now no no no
no that's really bad yeah he's gotta
keep a stable connection bishop before
played
okay the problem is
black's in zuk's wrong right
yeah i mean there's just nothing to do i
mean it means you can play f5 and then
after king e3 what's your king f7 you
can toggle between f7 and g6
at a minimum so maybe the winning idea
for white is like a bishop g5 at some
point to trade off the bishops and win
the b6 pawn
yeah and i was also thinking about
bringing a rook to c6 but the last thing
you want is to allow black stroke to
occupy the a file so right
and he does play rook c8
let's see how he follows up on this
bishop g5 i like your idea maybe bring
the king up to e3 first
oh
bishop b8
oh he's taking away the a7
bishop bishop c7 could that be his idea
okay but not when the king is this close
i don't think
hmm
although that is very appealing
maybe he's trying to king e3 king f4 and
just win the bonds
yeah that's also but no but then oh no
no no what am i i thought blackhead rook
takes b8 to bishop c7 but
rooks don't move like that
last night checked that would be a club
that's like the sarawan pieces you know
that move like multiple the hawker yeah
okay but fabio has no connection i see
okay now it's back
are you seeing this like it goes to no
yeah yeah the red
and now dmitry dropped dropping down to
three bars oh my gosh but father's down
to one bar uh he says it's offline
oh dimitri should move but that would be
such a terrible way to win but i mean
not his fault
oh he's down to one bar again no no
dimitri made a move he's done oh my gosh
oh he's got to move he's disconnected he
doesn't know no
wow that is absolutely tragic
this is what he's done he's down four
seconds he's gotta move two back one
move
move he's gone he's gone
oh my goodness
oh
terrible
and demetrius is not going to be happy
winning a game like this but again
it's not his fault
no it's not his fault at all you know he
was putting up the best defense he could
possibly
could and if it's the uh
internet pull the plug defense hey that
works too you know it's uh uh not
dimitri's fault
you hate to see that i mean what is
there to say besides fabiano was winning
and he outplayed dimitri there should be
an armageddon match but
um yeah
that was that's terrible it's terrible
for everybody it's terrible for the
event but it's nobody in particular's
fault except you gotta have good
internet connection
yeah sale iv
and
you're right what makes this
especially unpleasant is the fact that
fabi just played a brilliant positional
game and it was textbook
dimitri and draken doesn't get outplayed
like that every day
and just a sad sad end to what would
have been
an amazing on-demand win
wow well
whoo i think we're going to take a quick
breather but the players who remain
demetrion draken and dingley wren they
don't get much of a break because when
we return in a few minutes we will see
dingley wren take on wesley so and
demetria andre can take on vladimir
fedoceo some more from the rapid chess
championship finals presented by
coinbase in just a few minutes
so
[Music]
and we return here at the rapid chess
championship finals presented by
coinbase we have four players remaining
in the losers bracket as we head on into
the quarterfinals remember that later
today we do have hikaru nakamura against
jan napalm she in the winners final the
loser of that match drops down into the
loser's bracket double elimination form
at bedania we did just see dingley wren
he is in form right now he's looking
like he can contend for first place in
this tournament
he's playing better and better you might
remember he started with a very rocky
match
against jeffrey zhang but ever since
then he's been playing masterpiece after
masterpiece yesterday and now today just
disassembling parham aksubu like that
not an easy task and he gave a pity draw
in the second game but
he's winning that 100 times out of 100
ding is in a great spot and uh
he's just a force to be reckoned with
he is indeed but wesley so he had a bad
showing against hikaru nakamura
yesterday but we know how pinpoint
precise he can be so this is actually a
matchup of very precise technical
players for the most part and then as we
see it's fedo say versus undrained those
tbds they have names we know who they
are but don't worry everybody the
matchups will be great and i do want to
make a comment about this very quickly i
spoke to fabiano just now during the
break he has had shaky internet
connection it's not chess.com's fault i
know people love to blame them i love
the blind chestnut conference things all
the time i spoke to fabiano his internet
connection hasn't shaky all day he
understands he is not upset so please
stop your bickering in the chat and i
will continue to ignore you so don't
worry everybody but dania in all
seriousness we have some great matches
coming up next wesley and dingley wren
we've got andre kin and vladimir feroce
of the big fish so it's going to be a
fun time as we head to the next round
here in the losers right
big fish
1995. i'm
super excited for our two games and
wesley he's gonna have to put the memory
of that second game against the icaru
behind it because what often happens you
get this sour taste in your mouth you
start doubting yourself mine bad form
this tournament what's going on with me
but wesley he's so level-headed he's so
calm
i'm expecting a full strength showing
for him against single iraq
and for andreikin i mean you know he did
win that first game nicely so as much as
everyone wants to talk about the
disconnection he still deserves to be
where he is right he would have had an
armageddon game to settle things on
draken he played a really great
just
decisive attacking game against caruana
and for federal safe he's coming off a
loss so even though he's falling down
from the winners bracket his last match
his only match yesterday danya that was
a defeat so maybe he's feeling a little
shaky himself i have a pun for you
before the games begin just to set the
stage you know set the right kind of
mood are you ready to hear it
what do you say
uh what did dimitri's wife say when he
came home with a big paycheck
you're on drinking it in
[Music]
producer can you take me off camera
please i need to uh really it was so
smooth i didn't even have to alter his
last name it was organic that was really
just rough um
yeah one more sewing i guess i'll stick
to commentary
i got removed
my career as a as a stand-up comedian is
non-starter sadly yeah i think we're
gonna have to punch you from the bro i
don't have a very i don't have a very
supportive circle of friends
unfortunately
that's the first prerequisite
this game in the books next game
starting up right now so we do have uh
the game between dingley wren and wesley
so just getting underway here and the
other match is about to begin as well
but no surprises danya we have an
italian
game and the big question i guess is
where wesley will put his knight well
there's our answer yesterday against
ikaro he went for
am i remembering currently he went for
the fashionable knight c3 this time
going for the more traditional setup
with the pawn coming to c3 and ding
playing what absolutely everybody is
playing now a7 a five
and part of the reason everyone's
playing it is because of being they ran
you know he enjoys these lines and you
you know you're showing with arrows he's
doing just this the queen comes to a7
often just to put pressure on f2 forcing
white to play bishop e3 and it's such a
weird dynamic right who wants to put
their queen in the corner but the
queen's actually very well positioned on
a7 because white isn't in time to launch
a huge attack on the king side and this
is i believe called the rubenstein
maneuver named after akiba rubenstein
one of the sort of early earliest
positional players
uh he put together this maneuver
executed it against david yanovsky
uh in a gamer from the early 1900's
imagine how yanovsky's mind must have
been blown when the guy goes queen d8 b8
a7 and then he put it on c5 for a
completely different reason but now we
barely bat an eye when we see this i'm
going to be honest i'm proud of you for
getting a yanovsky reference into this
broadcast so uh that's a job well done
there daniel nolan
david good old dave yanovsky
big sasha
yanovsky well this uh this is a moment
where wesley he's going in the think
tank so dingley wren well prepared
wesley choosing his beloved italian and
then
sitting and thinking just trying to
figure out exactly this is it the right
time to push in the center and he says
yes the e4 pawn is loose you knew
exactly where i was going uh with this
but the e5 pawn will also become a
target i don't think this is the biggest
deal from black's perspective bishop d3
can be met by d5 potentially so it's a
really interesting dynamic
yeah d5
you could already have various tactics
knight takes d5 but then maybe some sort
of desperado sac with knight takes f2
before you know it you've got all sorts
of fireworks in the center and dingley
wren he never never shies away from
these complications he believes in
himself he doesn't care if it's prep if
it's schmep he's going to go for the
principled line and that's what makes
him so fun to watch there he goes
so bishop d3 and just knight back to f6
see yeah this looks iffy right you have
a double pawns he just whatever now it's
protected pawn so from g7 to g5 you have
uh connected pieces protected pieces and
he's claiming the open f file can be
good for him
yeah the open f file the fact that he
has a bishop in the open board the fact
that his rook is quickly coming to d8
and that queen on a7 is just sniping at
the f2 pawn keeping the knight on e3 at
bay
so
optically white's position does look
very impressive if you've got this
knight on e5 you can put it on g6 but
black will just say congratulations that
night is a paper tiger
and look at wesley so he's opening up
the queen's diagonal but only for a
moment because the night that was on e3
it was kind of controlled by the bishop
on e6 so now the night
discover double check yes
all right yeah i resigned
i'm sorry go on you know if you're
playing three checks i have a question
does double check count as two
anyone want to check the rule and one do
you want to check it's got to be one
yeah it must be but it's double check
right
i love three checks by the way little
known fact the only variant that i
actually enjoy okay well you know i'm
just getting your creative juices
flowing about three check here but it
also just this knight is coming to d4 so
wesley very intelligently rerouting that
night from 33 where it's controlled by
the bishop on e6 now it's not going to
be tamed once it gets out to d4
and of course you have to reckon with
the move c5 what is he planning on c5 is
it knight b5 or is there something more
appealing there's a queen sack
there's so many things to look at here
right because if you move the e5 knight
then the e6 bishop is hanging and you're
showing moves like knight b5 knight 66
i'm not actually sure all these moves
look very enterprising uh so i'm sort of
uh
choosing not to answer almost maybe
there's actually knight g6 your idea uh
seems to be a good one because after
rookie eight you take on e6 with the
rook and queen b3 queen b3 and the
knight it does its job for just long
enough
attacking the rook from two different
directions and white's got a pretty big
initiative here
and i can guarantee you the ding you can
almost sense the wheels turning in his
head he's thinking about c5 how was that
position even like it's so amazing where
i'm like i look at that i i see it on
the board i'm visualizing certain
variation like well that looks terrible
for black can't do that but it's just
even
at the camp i i taught in a couple of
months ago in atlanta i did an entire
hour-long lecture or the top group on
the fact that when you don't know the
evaluation of a position when it's
chaotic the evaluation is always the
same it's 0.00
that's just like a golden rule of
evaluating complex positions that
position looks so bad for black right
that's true your king is not very happy
there's a queen and a knife to surround
you
it's it's complicated it's complicated
it is definitely complicated chess is
complicated so
dingley wren he's burning some clock
here i haven't even looked at the other
game it's uh
actually not too far
yeah they're still
you know they're still getting dressed
in the morning
well we have both games on screen thanks
to our producer for getting this set up
for us we see on the right hand side the
queen just took on d5 that's dimitri
andreikin he was attacking this rook on
a putting some pressure towards the
black king as well uh nothing too major
though because everything's defended for
fedo save and then obviously the
left-hand side of the screen is wesley
silver sting the red we're just looking
at that so this this view i don't know
where to focus because both games are
just starting to get more interesting
yeah and i think we should go to the on
draken game because that is heating up
as we speak that is striking
on the queen side pushing b5 he still
needs to complete his development so
from a purely positional perspective
white's got better control over the
center right indisputable deep queen on
d5 the dark square bishop is coming out
to f4 with tempo but if fedex can set
his pieces in motion if he can get his
pawn to c4 and his knight to c5 you can
see how white's position could start to
unravel pretty quickly here so this is
actually sharper than it looks i agree
completely and on draken he knows when
to make moves like bishop f1 right he
just retreats to bishop all the way
there and it's those little moves that
really add up in chess and that's why on
draken is such a strong player uh he
brings the bishop back what's he going
to do in the future maybe he'll play g3
bishop g7 keto you mentioned bringing
that dark square bishop out to f4 that
makes a lot of sense and white has an
extra pawn if we cut the board in half
from the e to the h file so you would
maybe like to use the e5 pawn as a
battering ram and just throw those pawns
up as you're pointing out with all the
colors oh i'm so glad you're controlling
things i'm jackson pollock now so
i gotta live up to my name you're like
you're looking even more formulaic than
pollock pollock would just you know
splatter paint you have everything
nicely under control
yeah this is more like mondrian i don't
know
[Laughter]
oh my gosh we're gonna just talk about
different painters and pretend like we
know what we're talking about pretend
like i've been a museum in the last five
years oh i love museums so
you know if you wanna i love to say that
i love museums it's like the opera
i like to say that i appreciate the
upper but what i really like is sleeping
at the opera oh well you just you know
seem like a cultured lad so it all works
out but right now we'll see if this is
working out for fedocere because he's
burning a lot of clock right now donna
you were just saying how bishop b7 c4
all these type of ideas makes sense he's
trying to be accurate here because he's
stopping bishop f4 although if white
plays g3
now you have to deal with that and it
hurts a little more
we're on the same page and
fenesev was trying to get his priorities
in order did we stop bishop f4 to
complete the development one idea
against g3 might be
to play bishop b7
force the queen back and then maybe move
the rook from b and basically say hey
this is a long-term weakness and i've
largely taken the sting out of bishop f4
and now i've got an x-ray going against
white's queen and it's very important to
note that the b5 pawn can be captured
but white's king side light squares no
but you're doing all these principle
moves make sense right in knight f6
you're going to get the e4 pawns to be
in trouble 95 as well so the light
squares on the king side will be an
issue uh for white to deal with so no
i'm with you i think that the g3 may
look appealing but it's not actually
that scary for black to handle so now
it's on draken's turn to take some time
he goes queen h i was opening my mouth
to say that's a possibility
i don't get it though what's the point
but i thought yeah knight f6 for example
yeah where's that queen going after
knight f6
yeah that's what i didn't understand
nor do i really understand if i'm
totally honest with you
what the follow-up move is if i'm if uh
fedex plays a
general improving move on the queen side
such as c4
knight g5 can be easily met with knight
f6 right or am i missed or even h6
you're missing nothing i'm confused by
queen h5 i think that maybe on draken
feels like he doesn't have an advantage
and he's seeking
one out but this feels so artificial
artificial yeah
really really completing my sentences
of all the words that get abused do we
really come up with the same yeah
we're too in sync i think i need a new
co-commentator this is you know he's
telepathy going on it's making me feel a
little weird
yeah
you know it's one thing to be friends
with somebody it's nothing when they're
reading your mind
and there it is there it is
nice or what was the second word
that was the best one knight f6 knight
g4 so fetish say of not mincing his
words
and essentially forcing dimitri to show
to put his cards on the table here
and can you play f6 to kick the bishop
back and then maybe play f5 at some
point
or
this looks so odd
has dimitri bitten off more than he can
chew on the king's side here because the
queen all on its lonesome
is not exactly the most imposing piece
fc i like your idf's bishop d2 f5
and this is just like not an undraken
position i know i'm looking at this
setup of pieces and i'm like wait what
usually dimitri has the pieces on
perfect squares now he's just
discombobulated
and you know this is a fit of safe
position conversely he loves direct
contact he loves imbalance i mean who
wouldn't love this position you get an
initiative white's queen is
tumbling bumbling around the king's side
yeah he has definitely underestimated
black's initiative here or overestimated
his own and black's like two moves away
from winning you hit f5 and bishop c5
type moves you're just
crushing white on the spot so uh yeah
already dimitri might be an only move
territory
no he he is another issue if you play
queen g3 and say let's bail out
no you're not because of bishop e7 to d6
and then moving on to c5
white is worse and 0.5 might be
understating it
no this is looking like for example h3
you think the knight has to move but
black will throw an f5 and if you played
bishop g5
i think black beam played bishop c5
after bishop g5
oh that's so cool bishop c5
fg
and the knight cannot really move
because of i mean there's g3 there's
bishop takes f2 check ugh this is a
disaster
in the match
it looks not quite as bad as i would
assume but it's very bad for white
yeah i mean maybe white needs to make
a zen move like rookie one to e2 but if
you need to make those kinds of moves
you know that's a surefire sign that
your best days are behind you yeah
that's not what you want at all um
by the way i'm looking at the other game
just briefly and
it looks really scary but i'm guessing
that means it's all zeros because
dingley run with the black pieces he
doesn't just get in the scary positions
and lose usually he just yeah of course
of course this looks so scary for black
all right let's switch to that game of
course at 0.00 my lecture is aging
pretty well right now
yeah no we are
just ridiculous
and what
i mean to be honest with you i could
make a case for no i couldn't make a
case for black being better because
white always has this sort of perpetual
if he wants it
the point is if you play rook takes b7
then what exactly does black do
okay
vertex b7 was just played
yep it's on the board
because the check on d1 looks really
intimidating right but once the king
hides away on h2 there are no follow-up
checks what a common move by ding queen
c4 to e4
no problemo
and com is such an important thing to be
in chess and i'm looking i'm freaking
out i'm not even playing right i have no
responsibility for the result of this
game but i'm looking at the black king
which is
surrounded by white pieces and he just
yeah whatever i'm gonna trade queens and
make a draw
yeah he's like a pilot during turbulence
yeah uh everybody it's not a big deal
while you're like shaking and you're
like shaking and uttering prayers and
your pilot is like making sure his
orange juice doesn't spill
so this is like dingley randy putting
queen on e4 trade queens
and wesley can't really avoid the queen
trade because if you go queen b5
um
one of the kings gets checkmated and
him it's not the black king no it
certainly isn't forcing me with queen f2
at the end so that's a problem i think
that wesley
all right he could trade queens but he's
obviously not going to win that position
so maybe he should just force the draw
with knight g697 that seems like right
prudent thing to do
yeah and ding has plenty of time here
right around three minutes
is he flows he flirting briefly there
with king h7
no no the knight fa check would have
been
quite unpleasant
then king g8 back
queen e6 check
isn't there a queen on e4 oh wow you're
clever
you're gonna have the g7 pawn like that
also you can play rook take shoes oh
oh there's some beautiful complications
there but we'll leave those for behind
the scenes
i mean i'm interested now okay okay so i
was calculating king h7
um first of all queen takes f6 as an
insta draw
but knight f8 check is a double check
king g8
rook takes g7 check
following so far king takes you 796
check yeah now if you play king f7 you
walk into a check black has king g8
if you take the queen
then you allow an inter mezzo check on
dawn
but
but mike can actually take the knight
here
and amazingly black has no easy way
uh to force perpetual and white's got a
a ravaging attack here apparently of
course this is still people after rook
d7 because which position isn't equal
what do you need to do
it's like everything goes down to zeros
no it's actually
it's actually incredible right like
we as humans are like no that's too
scary eliminated
right
making kasparov noises yeah and then
nothing pans out the way you think it's
going to so it looks like in the game
west is probably just going to make a
draw is my guess but uh he's at least
going to study all of his options before
agreeing to that point
no for sure because
97 check just ends the game immediately
and it looks like
their match will be decided
in the next game ding with the white
pieces has been a force to be reckoned
with so a very good result for him in
this first game
for sure so let's go back to the other
game between on draking with the white
pieces fedor sayev with black
that position i mean not too much has
changed donya but it's looking even
better for fedor save he centralizes
queen now the b2 pawn is threatened
black has his extra pawn on the queen
side right you can start pushing those
pawns at the board
and called it by the way
oh is that exact line
yup
sorry proceed i just don't want to draw
attention to that i honestly didn't look
how we got here i just saw the current
position it's good to note how it
happened uh but wow bishop e7 what a
move oh i don't think
uh velodja should have allowed that
rookie eight because the dark squirt
bishop's being gone a lot of the teeth
is taken out of black's initiative black
is still better don't get me wrong but
after something like queen b4 is
actually doing all right is rook takes
f3 available at any point or
i guess not quite the king runs f1 into
e2
so takes
takes you wanted a check here i assume
yeah but king f1
ah somehow the king escapes see shaq
here there was c3 instead of
oh
i wouldn't move
wait
this is of course
does that say zeros
not anymore it does
but not that's wrong
probably because this position is
winning for black i don't know exactly
h5 just like pawn age is
promoting
or queen hvac oh queen tribe is nasty
yeah just everything is hanging queen h1
rook d8 is a threat
so i would say this is still scary but
typical typical on draken
just you can never bring the guy down
because queen takes b2 he has rook b1
and he's gonna win that b5 pawn isn't he
yeah i think he is queen i'm calculated
queen between roxy one queen c3 trying
to make contact with the other rook
but then that other rook's going to move
up
and then queen a5 but you're defending
very passively over there the rook can
go to a3
this position is actually incredible
connected passers everything's on a good
spot and yet black is not better
no
unfortunately for andre aiken
is not very fortunate for rondregan
because he's played
a meandering game i mean those pieces
went all over the place the queen to h5
the bishop g5 back to d2 all sorts of
odd maneuvering but he's
so strong that he can play like that and
still not suffer defeat at least not
based on the current position
yeah walking on a tightrope and now
forcing the queen trade the sad thing
for black is that queen d8 is literally
the only square available to the queen
and this game is going to end in peace
most likely and what's he thinking about
like i'm
there's nothing else to do right
rook d8 blunders e6 with check so
okay so we're in this endgame and this
okay it looks level but that doesn't
mean it's going to be a draw black is
probably the better side with the past
pawn
i might take i might take white here
okay because you can move the just every
time no just because robert has said he
would okay got it i thought you actually
would think the pawns would get
mobilized and you start pushing your f
and e pawns
yeah do i strike you as somebody who
makes decisions based on an objective
assessment of the position come on
no but i i actually do think that
perhaps white has
some pond mobility later down the line
also always worried about vladimir's
connection when he gets down below a
minute
i actually you said that and i was
looking at his connection to see if he's
good but it seems like he's all right
and one thing about fedo save is he's
very classically trained so he's happy
to make a draw with black right if he's
better of course he'll try but if the
position is unclear he's the type of
player who says all right i'll settle
for that draw because i get white in
game two so i don't think looking in
this position he's thinking about
winning he's just like all right i'm
happy to
let this fizzle out
okay eight yeah and you don't want to do
anything
ridiculous right just because you were
better earlier does not mean that you
know how many times have we seen that
one player gets upset they overpress and
then they end up losing
too many times
it's happened to us it certainly has i'm
i'm thinking about
fedo save and i feel like the guy just
loves online chess
yeah he does
and it's been really good for him
because he's succeeded in so many
different events
yeah he was even trying his hand at
streaming a couple of months ago i was
helping him out a little bit
wasn't as much into that you know he
realized how hard it is to monitor the
chat at the same time
and uh but
he loves blitz he loves online chess i
feel like he'd be a fan favorite though
if he decides
he's awesome i was i was on a stream all
the time i was modding the chat you were
a mod for him that's so adorable yeah i
was helping him uh helping him help me
set up well i know you two are long time
friends so
you know how he plays you know him
personally and i mean he really has been
a tremendous force uh these last couple
years you know
since kova began so uh it's great to see
him continue to thrive because he's a
really nice guy and he's super super
strong
yeah he's one of the nicest nicest
people in chester i know he's very
humble
and uh you know i remember calling him
when he made 2700 for the first time
because he jumped from like 26 40 to 27
20 in a couple tournaments he pulled
right ahan's name and sam shanklin
gukesh a couple of players have done
that since then
and he wasn't too impressed with himself
he was already thinking you know about
why he's not 27.50
and he's got that attitude he demands a
lot from himself
and he's afraid of absolutely no one we
were talking about that yesterday that's
what makes him such a dangerous opponent
across all time controls well i'm going
to be honest you know
dimitri is making progress here i was
about to say i'm a little afraid for him
in this game because this king is
starting to walk up the board and if
that king keeps going black is going to
be in some big trouble because the king
on g8 is stuck on the last rank
f4 is possible to defend the g2 pawn i
like it
dimitri
i just need to be tree fed a save
vladimir on draken
he's making progress here both sides
down below 20 seconds okay we got a
bullet screaming
and both of these players are stellar at
bullet i'm drinking above 3 100. uh
better say if surprisingly under 2900 i
would have thought he was higher uh but
still both these guys really can
show a great class during bullet chests
this is getting really concerning king
e3 and f5 as well let them push e6
exactly
pedestal defending from behind
he wants to give ladder of back checks
on e1 when necessary
okay good defense by fedo save just
covering his loose pawn
i think you have to try f5 there it is
he does
okay this is getting a little dicey
rookie one king of four
oh my gosh pg five three round two f6
great move bishop d5
pull
out of the danger zone
bishop g6 just take the oh my god
rook c55
no
no that wasn't the move oh rookie five
king of six and rook states mate
oh my god and i don't see a different
move for fetishive king f6 and e6 he's
going oh my gosh
oh he is king d and f6 oh he came with
king d8
because of rick d7 check winning the
bishop and now he's gonna play e6 it's
complete it's over
rook move oh we need trade rooks trade
bishop g687 oh my gosh or even the
immediate rook d7 wins the bishop
it's over
holy cannoli
and maybe
he just assumed that it would maybe
assumed it would just be a draw they had
no losing chances and
i guess i also made that assumption and
well unfortunately for vladimir he's now
facing a one-nil deficit
didn't we all
the other game by the way is still going
but it's going to end in a draw
well i don't i'm not going to make any
claims anymore
i'm shocked
white can't lose this game that's for
sure
fede was in the driver's seat the entire
game when they got into the end game you
just kind of assume yeah and drake and
defended well okay time to give him a
draw
before you know it you turn the tables
completely that was unbelievably
impressive he's such a beast
yeah
he really is
such a beast
take the phone wait why does this bar is
that's a slight favoritism for black no
okay yeah black's better
what are you talking about you don't
realize that do you need to go back to
uh it's a basic training here yeah black
is better
on the better side of this draw for sure
but
dingley red holding steady with the
black pieces i really can't wrap my head
around the fact that feathers have lost
that game i mean he outplayed on draken
throughout the early stages then it
looked like you just settled for a draw
but donna you're the prophet for a
reason you called it that white would
have some chances to push those pawns
and black's pawn on c4
it couldn't move a muscle
yeah i could just kind of feel it he was
getting low on time
it's hard to defend at all after you've
been in charge the entire game
it's not that you're tilted it's just
that you're not in a mindset in a
defensive mindset and dimitri and draken
knows how to push the position from
every little angle every little squeeze
doesn't leave any stone unturned and we
saw that once again there if we pull up
that game just really quickly danya
this is a good example of
if there's if you're going to make a
draw you want to make it immediately
because the longer the game goes on the
more chance you give your opponents i'm
wondering if there was a moment i don't
actually know of one where
fedocere could have just
forced pieces off the board forced to
draw in some way
i think there was i i think it was here
and i think the move was rook c8 oh wow
and
draken would have been forced to trade
me you're not going to leave the
blackrock behind the pawn
but oh and there's a beautiful detail
rookie five you can actually play king
f7
it looks like a blunder
oh but the pawn is unstoppable there in
that line the game has begun so we're
interrupted but i think you got the
point rick would have forced the rooks
off the board that bishop end game i
think would have been a lot easier for
fedex to hold okay well that answered
the question right from the get-go there
was a way to trade off pieces but we are
in game two you see
uh the the players are going to uh flip
so andreikin has black in this game uh
so is black so the the players are
upside down but the games are just
getting underway here
chalula look at that h4 h5 by ding over
on the left side of your screen
oh he's pushing this has actually become
so topical
in
recent years this h pod pushes against a
fianchetto just gaining space forcing
that bishop out of its home but that
could be a pawn that's gone too far
yeah it's an incredibly committal
decision
not only to put it on h5 but to drag it
all the way to h6 you're also closing
down the king side which means you're
not going to
be able to access black's king that
easily once it castles king's side
so in this position after bishop f6
what is the follow-up he just castle
that's funny because normally when you
push your h-pawn you think you're going
to get an attack but there is no attack
there's no tension between pawns so
right now h2
you know this is the game between okay
so wesley should have good insight into
this position at least some insight
because amin top tabai played like this
against lavonna ronin at the olympia
with white
uh amin was white lavon was black but
wesley was on the next board was sitting
next to them yes so uh this position
should be at least a bit familiar to
wesley who also plays c4 himself in some
games so we'll see how this one
continues but dingley wren after
throwing his eight trunk board he's the
one who's spending a little bit more
time
imagine showing this to to capable let
me read out white's last four moves h4
h5 h6 castle's king side knight f3 to h2
and now d3 just going about his business
just another day at the office i mean of
course it makes perfect sense right you
have this great bishop on g2
so that's an excellent minor piece
and
knight to e4 will attack the bishop on
f6 and the pawn on c5 so the west just
goes rook c8 he's not worried about it
no and you often want to move c4
yourself as black because that improves
the positioning of your knights over
there on the queen side
i i don't know if i'd be
so keen on giving up the bishop pair
in in a pretty wide open middle game
ding by the way can also consider the
very thematic idea a4
trying to push the other pawn to a6 how
often do you see that
pawns on a6 and h6 by move 15
almost never so that would be kind of
funny actually but the question is do
you want to give away the b4 square we
saw parham take that b4 square against
ding in the earlier match today it's a
different position now and ding says did
it once let's do it again that was fun
crazy
and wesley could try to halt the
progress of the pawn by playing a6 if he
plays a5 he correspondingly gives up the
b5 score i don't think we're gonna see
that
so decisions to be made here for wesley
i think ding once again has gotten
himself a good position of the white
pieces shocking sentence dingley wren
has a good position i know
crazy and look at wesley he's taking a
creative approach to stop that pawn in
its tracks he puts his knight on a5
which covers the b7 pawns the bishop on
g2 is staring in the long diagonal but
it's covered for now and look at that b3
square so by playing a4 you not only
give away b4 but potentially b3 so that
knight can start causing white some
trouble over there on the queen side
potentially in conjunction with the
bishop that drops back to e6 the other
thing i pointed this out with an arrow i
think wesley tries to take the sting out
of the move 94. now this no longer
attacks the c pawn the rook has
reestablished contact with it so if he
wants to preserve his bishops he can
drop it back to h8 now he might still
want to take on e4 but
my guess is that he's going to want to
keep both of his bishops intact for the
time being he would prefer to keep the
bishops but i think the issue that
bishop d2 is about to happen so this
knight on a5 is quickly targeted and
that's why he decided to take on e4 he
didn't want to do that let's be clear
about it but he had to and it was the
correct decision great call and he
follows it up you called it as well c5c
rook
responds
i like the way dig plays okay
we gotta
i'm gonna i'm gonna mute myself you go
ahead
yes stop it okay stop it stop it oh my
gosh well
what is black's idea in this position
because white now is the bishop pair
and a potential attack on the kings and
the knight on h2 it looks silly but it's
going to g4
yeah and he's keeping this move in
reserve i think a lot of players
would be itching to play this move asap
but we know that the threat is stronger
than this execution
the eval bar of course it's giving
zeroes
but
i i really like white's position here it
just seems more fun
to play with white here now this looks
really pleasant for
especially because there's some
confusion in the mix right now there's a
rook on a3 there's a knight in h2
there's a pawn on h6 like white's pieces
are scattered but black doesn't have a
plan and white has the long-term
advantage of the bishop pair so e6 by
wesley we know how calm of a player he
is he is very objective he pushes upon
e6 maybe he wants bishop e7 maybe he
wants bishop g5 to trade those dark
square bishops and go after the h6 pawn
at some point and if you play knight g4
and that bishop moves out the way then
there's f5 to follow for black with a
fork
great point and black doesn't really
have any targets so it's important not
to overstate the case here i'm kind of
biased when i look at this bishop but
you know you can't judge a position
based on the placement of
one piece or one particular factor this
position is a lot more complex than that
so
of course the fight is still ahead
right and the b2 pawn is a little bit
loose over there so that bishop probably
should remain on c1 for white for the
time being and it's not clear how to
continue with your development or gain
more control of squares
yeah knight b3 is potentially also
in the cars the b2 pawn is kind of a
weakness so
position remains incredibly complex we
will keep an eye
as this game heads toward what should be
a really entertaining middle game
for sure so let's speaking of
entertaining middle games yeah let's go
to that other game because i see a very
fascinating pawn structure between
vladimir putin and dimitro and draken
and if we remember andreikin made it
through to this point uh he was the
beneficiary of a disconnection though he
won a very nice game one in game two he
got outplayed when he had black and
right now out of the opening donya i
mean i really like
white's position i think fedor sayev has
excellent chances
and he has the threat of bishop takes e5
which explains on draken's
last move now white
definitely better here queen a4
attacking a7 this is almost reminiscent
of the first game not structurally but
in the sense that a dragon grab or fedex
grabs control of the initiative early on
but this time he's going to have to find
a way to keep his phone on the gas pedal
and it's just a shame that it's a
must-win situation because he's kind of
like the better chess between the two of
them thus far
and in this game he has a very very nice
look at this bishop on d6 it's a pawn
the pawns on c7 and c5 are defended by
that bishop so that's the good news but
with the a7 pawn there as well they're
all spread apart it's like split in
bowling you don't want this type of
position and where is black's
alexa i like some commentating
[Laughter]
no i'm not going for a walk right now
alexa
i was going to ask you where is black's
play if not for the f5 but i think that
black kind of has to sit and do nothing
maybe f5 will work out but it's one of
those moves you play to get play and
then you regret it immediately
well you kind of have to get play
because fetishes just grabbed speaking
of going on walks the queen going on a
little walk and taking on a seven
fearless by feta sev if the black bishop
were to be on c6 right now rook a8 would
trap the queen so in response to queen
c6 uh to bishop c6 the queen would have
to evacuate to a5 i'm gonna make the
call that i'm draken is going to play a
five the most important thing is to
choose the appropriate time to do it i
agree with you it's incredibly committal
but how else is going is he going to
manufacture counter play right now i
think it works out perfectly for him and
there's something fascinating that if
white could play rook b1 takes b7 like
let's just you know think about the rook
on that square the queen gets trapped at
the rook
that's really cool
yeah but the bishop goes to c6 and the
queen is going to venture back like you
were suggesting and
i like
fedex position he just stole a pawn
he did
and he's left to tell the tale and on
draken seeking his fortunes on the queen
side i was going to mention this move
is he trying to double on the b file and
immobilize this bishop so let's bring
that queen ooh
knight knight d2 wait but you're giving
up this d3 pawn
is federicife relying on his apon to
just win the game
but the issue is after rook 63 you kind
of pointed this out rook a8
is a massive threat so you can't go
knight d5 here well you can the queen's
under attack because you play c takes d5
well you don't have room oh and i forgot
yeah when the
course yeah no longer has access to that
square
duh
duh don yeah but no but i think this is
actually going wrong for fedor save the
movie can just move
we'd have seven between these things
that d3 pawn is not just a little bit
important that was an essential pawn to
keep
yeah and after queen f7 how do you
defend against roke8
sounds absurd but it's a serious threat
can you just go back before knight to d2
because i'm just sure i'm wondering here
and i think that maybe photoshop a
little bit too quickly like what was
wrong with queen d2
i don't know yeah rook fba and now maybe
queen c2 is a bishop
okay i could see why this would look a
little odd
but yeah this seems like
white clearly is happy to keep an extra
pawn
yeah bishop a4 maybe you can stick a
knight on d5 and then drop it back to c3
or something
weird weird decision by fedexaev to to
go for these adventures
and it it seems to me that they're gonna
backfire yeah especially because he got
exactly what you could hope for out of
the opening he won a pawn
black's compensation was clear since the
b follow control was nice but it what
didn't seem like it was sufficient for
equality so i think that we saw earlier
parham just throw everything at dingle
red and that clearly didn't work but for
federal save he decided to do that mid
game and i don't think he should have
switched his approach
agree completely
and knight takes c7 here also doesn't
seem to work the queen will be
overloaded
no he's he's bitten off more than he can
chew here rookie three might have been
the only move
and what a move dislodge the rook from
d3 that's a great move rook a8 of course
you play queen takes aid and get two
rooks for the queen
wow that's uh that's like a game
potentially match saving move i still
like the contours of black's position
but now i see some of the promise for
white the bishop on d6 is still bad
obviously and you have this outside pass
pawn for white so the knight md5 looks
good i don't hate it anymore
yeah you just need to untangle your
queen
from the net that it's currently in
maybe on draken couldn't come back to
the f5 idea oh take c3 and f5 sorry no
other game a big big moment just
happened
so we'll we'll get to that game
look at this last move or last couple
moves at this point go back a few
i i just happened to catch it rook takes
c1
happened from black
whoa bishop f3 first of all they traded
queens f5
dragging the knight bang
bishop takes b2
just rooks in five
so ding decides to go after the knight
and we have this position on the board
super complicated which of course means
that it's equal
because that's that's just how chess is
played these days that's how the sausage
is sliced well it looks like white's
going to win the b7 pawn but if you take
that you probably lose a4 so yeah that's
probably why this is
seemingly equal
yeah i don't see an alternative to rook
takes a7
and then i think i guess black plays
bishop c5
yeah this is this is another i just saw
i caught rook take c1 as it was
happening and i didn't know what the
evaluation was but now that we're here
i'm like oh okay maybe it wasn't as
exciting as i would have hoped
yeah i guess we're going to armageddon
for the first time today
well i guess
rich games well we still have these four
players duking it out trying to make
their way through the losers bracket
coinbase wants to hear from you chat
who will make it out of the losers
bracket which of these four players on
draken dingley wren wesley so or
vladimir fett 07. we should note there
could be somebody else because if hikaru
or
yan whoever loses that match drops down
to losers bracket they will join this
question so
some someone else might not be the worst
answer in the world just trying to help
you out chat get involved and continue
enjoying the coverage here but dania
this game yeah you're right it looks
like it's going to be a split of the
point once again which
only means free chest for all armageddon
yeah and and armageddon between these
two players is going to be fascinating
i'm actually going to be interested in
who makes the higher bid because it
seems to me that both of these players
like to have the extra time and play
white
so we are in for a wild ride if indeed
this game fizzles out as
whoa
what it may still may still we may still
see some adventures here and it looks
like terrible for white to like bishop
e3 pawn takes but the bishop 103
obviously better than knight on b6 so a
good decision in the end
great decision of course rook b5 forces
the immediate draw and i don't know
fight has no alternative what else is
the rook going to do we might also see a
repetition of the rook a7 bishop c5
that feels likely because the point
after rook a7 is that you're going to
play with a5 yourself and then win this
b7 pawn and then black's in big trouble
so that's why bishop c5 is so important
in this exact a5 the knight moves out
the way and then you don't even get b7
and your rook is trapped
yeah literally
and you only can go to d5 as you're
pointing out if you go anywhere but d5
white has the
uh escape hatch through b7
right so
this is uh looking like a repetition oh
or not rook
ding is flirting with
the idea of playing for a win
but is he playing for a win or a loss
that's the million dollar question
because wesley could take this pawn
and
i believe that's called a past pawn in
some circles
and um someone told me that passponds in
the end game can be dangerous
you have learned correctly so there's a
reason why you're the sensei and that
looks a bit worrisome if that pawn can
get up the board the bishop on f8 is
perfectly placed it protects the black
king music protect the king he's not in
trouble but if e6 is to fall then that
king could be in a bit of danger and the
bishop one of it covers the b4 square
when you start pushing the punt up the
board so i actually think that wesley
he's really going to dig deep here and
maybe even try to
play for an advantage and i don't
honestly really see an alternative to
knight takes a four because if he plays
king f7 here to defend e6
then ding will play a5 he'll gladly save
the pawn
move back to b5 and the pressure on b7
could get unpleasant i'm positive that
that is also a draw
you know there are
many roads lead to rome here
but
you know i wouldn't be able to resist
can i show you a quick line there so
king f7 a5
knight where d7 sure let's say rook b5
when you play knight c5 i think that
bishop takes b7 oh
oh that's beautiful rook if knight b7
and a6 if rook b7 this is such a classic
timeless idea that knight is on the
worst possible square on the entire
chessboard wherever you move it the pawn
moves up to a7 and it's unstoppable yeah
so the king was on d7 right exactly
right so it's one of those things you
learn in certain endgame positions and
that's what had the uh the cogs turning
in my head about that possibility
i think the french study mr andre sharon
first kind of
uh
uncovered these beautiful ideas in the
early 1900s so
very good call by you and we have more
transformations here as wesley decides
to go after the h-bomb instead of the
a-pawn
okay so what is ding's idea of right now
if he plays a takes b6
with the opposite bishops that should
just be a draw but now all of a sudden
wesley has a pawn ahead and if he plays
taking on e3 with the rook then just
knight c4 and a5 will he'll think
and then try to play rook c5 or
something
or a b5
i'm as skeptical as your knight c4 here
ah but then rook b5
no ding ding decides to bail out
and maybe wisely so
but why did he he'd have to give him a
pawn to get here right he could have
done this he was necessary
this was necessary he's just saying that
he tried he put in the effort that's all
he wanted to make known
okay so this is for sure going to be a
draw
shall we
take a quick look-see at the other game
and how that's progressing right let's
definitely look there so we'll get more
from wesley and dingley wren in
armageddon but this game could be the
last if on draken does not lose and what
a position this is dania what's the
material count even white has the
outside pass pawn who has the safer king
probably also white although e4
if you're not looking closely that could
be scary for white in addition to being
scared for black of course you know
quite a chat is the media problem but if
the queen were to move away from c3 then
e4 comes and it's white's king that
could be in some danger the crazy thing
is e4 actually is possible here it
should be considered because he's not
immediate checkmate i probably would not
play it unless you're absolutely sure
that the counter play against white's
king is going to be worth
allowing a check like that on h8 in fact
queen h8 might almost say a blunder
h2 that's that's ridiculous i don't
think we're gonna see that just seems
unnecessarily risky and also did that
just happen
what did you just say did he actually
just make that move he actually did is
this dimitro and draken or yeah mikhail
tall like
oh my gosh so
he was knight f1 without bishop e5 as
possible isn't that rook takes f1 of the
perpetual
rook
f1 queen f4 and then oh i can't go to e2
g4 oh it's a draw he's gonna win the
match it's immediately a draw and that's
what you call a case of the incorrect
move order because if you threw in queen
h a check the king would be on f7 so
after rook takes f1 rook f1 there would
be a check to the black king wow
incredible and he saw that
he saw it so quickly
and this is why we keep saying top
players are incredibly versatile dimitro
and draken yeah he's a solid player but
when it comes when push comes to shove
he will find the tactical way to save
himself and he did just that
no he's
you don't become a 3100 bullet player
without being incredibly good at these
short tactical ideas
and he leans back in his chair you can
sense that he knows this match is in the
bag
that means we'll be able to focus on one
and only one armageddon game by the way
rook takes f1 loses because a bishop
takes h2 check which you don't expect
like at this point bishop h2 you usually
leave with the queen but now queen f4
and if king is happening no it's not it
is oh my gosh it's on the board and
fedex i mean you understand why he does
this he's testing his opponent king you
won bishop g3 the problem isn't that you
lose the rook the problem is that you
lose the rook with check because
otherwise there would have been a made
on g7 yes and
[Laughter]
that's a that's a gentlemanly draw but
actually can we just show if queen took
on h2 instead of the bishop why this is
so different because if queen takes h2
and now queen f4
the king could run to e1 and you don't
have bishop g3 check because your
queen's in the way so this is why bishop
takes issue leading with the
less valuable piece shockingly was the
way to go in this attack
yeah here you have the services of your
bishop so you have the same position
where the bishops on h2 rather than d6
therefore you have the check and
therefore you get to take the rook with
a check dimitron draken another
excellent win another resilient gritty
effort
yeah seriously he job well done by on
drake and he gave up the a7 pawn sought
counter played down the b file was able
to win his pawn back and then he
neutralized the pressure that ferocious
was launching i just want to go back to
that one moment though dania when e4 was
played if we can
yep because it's move order we stress
its importance but after this moment
queen h a check
king f7
now knight to f1 you can't take on f1
because rook takes f1 check to the black
hat
yes so that was where fedo said lost all
of his winning chances was by not
throwing in this check that's so hard to
see though because like you pointed out
queen 8 kind of abandons the king so
your instinct is to keep your queen
close to close to your chest
but ironically it produces the opposite
effect
yes indeed well we are now waiting to
hear the bids from dingley wren and
wesley so i'm very curious to know what
would you guess these players are going
to bid i think they're going to bid
pretty high you know i think we might
see some eights and nines
no you think that they both just really
want the white pieces
i don't know why i think that but ding
has been so effective with white in this
tournament
and his only achilles heel
and once again there's only one so only
is an unnecessary word his achilles
has been you know his time usage and in
an arm again game with no increment i'd
be a little bit worried for his clock
yeah and i'm trying to think about this
because wesley is a very good bullet
player
ding proved to be a good ball player in
the speed chess championship against
hikaru and wesley apparently is thinking
about his bid so uh great work by our
team behind the scenes and talking with
the players making sure they know
exactly the format even if they've had
armageddon before sometimes you forget
uh you know it's good to remind them but
the team is just about getting us uh
the bids but while we have a minute
let's show you the hired player resume
of none other than ding lee wren and he
didn't play in the rapid chess
championship during the season and it's
not because he didn't want to
unfortunately for dingley ren and other
chinese players it is quite late there
when the rcc began but uh he is going to
play in the world championship because
magnus carlson decided to abdicate the
throne he is number two overall in the
world rankings and his special talent is
a joke because uh while he was about to
be interviewed he would always ask out
of just genuine curiosity how many
people are watching he loves the fact
that more and more people are getting
into chess he's a great interviewee and
right now he has to be great with the
black pieces because danya ding bid
seven minutes wesley bid seven minutes
and 15 seconds
so ding gets black with a three minute
deficit on the clock
that's a pretty big deficit normally we
see eight minutes even sometimes 8 30
so he's going to have to play fast in
the opening and i think that's going to
be critical it's going to be critical
for ding to equalize and by move 15 he
wants to have
you know no less than let's say four or
four and a half minutes but it feels
like you know they're both immovable
objects right they're
they're not really getting anything that
game one when ding was black it looks
scary but things like that what are you
you guys are are foolish it's fine and
then in game two there when wesley uh
was playing with black ding was in you
know playing for a little bit of
something but it was neutralized so now
we'll see what ding does in another
italian game most likely and here we go
there it is knight f6 this time and
no same thing put the puts the bishop on
c5 wesley refrains from the fried lover
especially after ding's masterpiece
against parham
and this time he puts the bishop on g5
another fashionable line
yeah this is uh g5 bishop g3 and black
often castle there it is right into this
and we saw some great games in lines of
this in fact pantala hare krishna beat
nerdy because i know the words beat
abducetaro back yeah yeah you don't hear
that very often these days but harkish
has scored a great victory from the
black side of position just like this
gyan chistop dude plays this from the
black side vita guzrati pretty much the
who's who of chess so it is a an opening
consistently played at the top level
and lots of decisions to be made for
both sides white i i indicated this move
h4 trying to exploit the hook on g5 but
that could also backfire if the king
side gets dried up that would definitely
be in black's favor you have to watch
out for d5 black has to watch out for d4
as well as queen side expansion so it's
a tremendously rich position
structurally where the pawn structure is
completely undefined
and i like this from wesley's
perspective given ding's time situation
i think
this kind of line is kind of what the
doctor ordered in an armageddon game
and daily wren he has
just a ton of experience in this
position he played i believe either not
in this exact question right now but
against yanchez and the candidates he
neutralized due to his first move edge
and here the thing about this position
is how does white actually make progress
the f5 square sometimes a little bit
loose because you're pawn's in e5 and g5
and the bishop on b6 is about to be
captured it would seem but h4 as you're
pointing out it actually doesn't
accomplish much because black closes
down the king side with g4 then puts a
knight on h5 and then plays f5 that is
why the king's on g7 right now
yep to avoid the potential for some sort
of a discovery check and wesley actually
decides to castle kingside which
bears its own risks because now black's
pawns could potentially steamroll
white's minor pieces here which are kind
of sitting ducks
but ding decides to develop his light to
our bishop instead
kind of walking into knight e3
yeah that's a bit curious why you would
allow knight e3 you don't want to
capture an e3 and open up the f file
that's for sure
i mean ideally you would want to have
your cake and eat it too you'd want to
take on b6 and then somehow re
retool the other knight and maneuver it
to e3 but that takes a long time
right so 93 maybe just bishop d7 is kind
of forced just
cover the f5 square it doesn't look like
a retreating move you want to play but
i'm also looking to clocks dania and
wesley has spent quite a deal of time to
get to this position so it feels like
ding thus far has been the more
comfortable player
yeah impossible to say which direction
this game is going to go
h5 can be pretty reliably met with h3
i or so i thought but this is happening
so h3s are h4 suddenly for black
and if i drop my bishop back you drop
your bishop back and that pen becomes a
big problem
okay this is
very spicy
so bishop h2 bishop h5 then the f5
square is finally up for grabs
but ding is happy to give that square
away
all in the name of this pin
and that pin is like an everlasting pin
it's not one you're getting out of so
well you could play queen d2 you could
even allow bishop takes f3 and maybe
wesley will
that looked scary but instead he takes
sound is right
dark square bishop because now
you can allow certain ideas towards the
king side because there's no pin from b6
to g1
and h64 is in play that's a candidate
move right because
all of a sudden what could end up
happening black skin can end up caught
on the crossfire after something like
queen d2
well let's see what wesley does here
knight h4 is even an impossible move
d2 play
f6 is that available
it should be six knight h6
i think black's actually quite fine here
yeah it seems like you're going to
stabilize in the king side i think
wesley maybe you could have taken this
pawn on g5 instead of playing f takes j
oh whoa whoa whoa whoa
wait why would you
what are we missing
well there's either queen takes g5 or
even knight takes you back because rook
h1 is not possible the king escapes
three two
i don't understand this at a what
just knight takes g5 no
oh
no
rook h5 and queen h5
and after knight f7 is our queen h8 no
the king escapes as you were just saying
that's very close also that i don't have
seven defends the h8 square no no but
i'm giving up my queen to checkmate you
was my idea but it doesn't actually
check me i see
this is what dink's going for this also
looks bad
okay i love moves like that because i
was so tunneled on taking on f7 oh
bishop d1
bishop d1 1-0 and i didn't notice it i
pretty sure didn't notice it i'm sorry
to interrupt you no no you didn't
interrupt anything ding looked and he
kind of like grabbed his head exactly
like this he saw bishop d1 as soon as he
brought his knight back to e7 but that
wasn't i mean that was just completely
cloud there was no need to give up that
pawn at all
and you see wesley clapping
oh my gosh wesley has been so
celebratory throughout the rapid chess
championship we saw in the final week of
the season you were covering that right
when he uh beat jan napomishi yeah in
the uh final of that week and he just
was jubilant and he also beat hikaru
nakamura in the penultimate round yeah
wesley it means a lot to him and he's
you know he loves chess and he's playing
really well he is but the way ding
unraveled there that's crazy it on move
18 if you had told me the game would end
four moves later i would not have
believed you so a frustrating end to the
tournament for ding but he can hang his
hat on
so many of the masterpieces that he
played especially with the white pieces
so
a good performance at the end of the day
wesley
is the more stable player in the
armageddon
so wesley so makes it through he will
meet
dimitri and draken in the next round of
the losers bracket but we're going to
the winner's side of things right now
because when we come back from this
break we will have none other than ikaru
nakamura and yon napomshi clashing for a
spot in the grand final do not want to
miss that in just a few here at the
rapid chess championship finals
presented by coinbase
[Music]
whoa
my
[Music]
so
a unique online event with enticing high
stakes the inaugural season of the rapid
chess championship delivered its fair
share of big names and big moments andy
karu nakamura is going to win how did he
do that
with more than 50 grand masters claiming
cash prizes over six months of weekly
competition it was also home to a
healthy helping of big surprises e6
wandering up seven this has been such a
roller coaster awarding over half a
million dollars in cash money
but year one of the rcc is not done yet
the rapid chess championship is
presented by coinbase and the finals are
finally here
the brightest stars from the regular
season including hikaru nakamura fabiano
caruana alexander grisham and more are
back to take a run at a fresh 150 000
and the very first rapid chess
championship title
also in the mix the familiar faces of
top players known for dominating elite
online chess events how will they handle
the pressure of chasing a championship
and crashing this party as wild card
invites some of the most famous names in
competitive chess drop in to stake their
claim to the thirty thousand dollar
first prize
my friends
it's the inaugural rapid chess
championship final who will make history
as our first rcc champion what surprises
are still to come
we are soon to find out
hey there software engineers tired of
getting random calls and texts with bad
job matches hired connects you to over
10 000 employers worldwide through one
easy dashboard no cover letters or
applications just upfront salary data
and dedicated candidate experience
managers to support your incoming offers
take control of your career with hire
and here we have a question for you from
hired on hired what percentage of
interview requests in san diego were for
remote roles so
the answer will come tomorrow take your
stab at this question
would it be a b c or d you got four
options you choose not up to me up to
you but right now it's up to these two
players danya hikaru nakamura and yon
napomshi to determine who will be
slotted into the grand final and who
will drop down to the loser's bracket to
await the winner of wesley so versus
dimitri on draken man could not possibly
think of a better semi-final matchup
what's more fun than watching hikaru and
yan watching hikar and yan when both of
them are in incredible form they have
been
absolutely unstoppable from the
candidates onward
we're in for a barn burner
we certainly are
so here we go it is hikaru versus yon
time i'm excited and knight f3 on move
one are we getting into b3 system
that is definitely the likeliest decaro
briefly deviated from that in the last
couple of games to play one d4 but back
to his roots now
okay but john just taking control if
you're not gonna put your pawns in the
center he says i'll gladly throw mine up
and there's
we've mentioned this a bunch right
there's that hikaru effect where it
sometimes seems like he gets in other
people's heads remember his camera's a
minute behind so his reactions are not
about the position at play but something
that must have happened
60 seconds ago but dania i don't think
yon napomshi is going to be phased by
car nakamura he played magnus carlsen
for a world chess championship
yeah there's maybe two or three players
who are essentially immune from the
hikaru effect and wesley is one of them
eric pointed this out a couple days ago
and jan is another one ghana is immune
from any effect because he's yonder
pondichin he is supremely confident he's
fast and he's got kind of the right
skill set to give hikaru trouble but
igaro is one of the only players to give
yon trouble at the candidates tournament
so
very very unpredictable and we have
already quite an interesting position
this is sort of a kali system
but it's a little bit spicier because
there's a possibility of taking on c5
right and in these types of positions
when you take on c5 uh you need to be
careful as black because sometimes white
is able to cling onto that pawn and say
i am going to have extra material but of
course after dc5 there are options to
win that pawn directly whether it's a
queen a5 check or just as you're
pointing out push that pawn in the
center and win the pawn back with your
bishop and it's captured
ikaru with the principled move and i
would say there are three candidate
moves there is of course e5 which i
think a lot of people are tempted with
but people forget that white can hear
play bishop b5 and very often black
bites off more than he can chew nothing
is developed and jan
rightly so going for a more conservative
approach and we have some sort of a
reverse
queen's game but accept it almost
we do and jan upon machi in recent years
since he won the
candice for the first time in 2020 21 it
feels like he just has this calmer
approach to chess it's not just because
he's sipping on tea every time he plays
but his actual style has changed at his
heart you know in his heart of hearts he
is this aggressive tactical player but
instead of forcing the issue he has been
able to say i am going to
play when it comes to me rather than
saying i'm just going to go in there and
try to checkmate you so i really like
the way he's been playing in recent
years and look at how quickly he's
responded to karu's opening he's become
more versatile we saw a great example of
the new yon the yan 2.0 and his
armageddon game against vladimir
fetishet but catalan a gritty positional
effort not forcing anything
and jan showing us that it is possible
to change yourself even when you're over
for sure and i just want to quick give a
quick shout out to tfs
2832 for a very nice compliment i
appreciate that and greetings to you in
germany so thank you here's your shout
out uh from the from me to the chat
shocking i know daniel
yeah what did he say to get you to do
that what kind of spells were cast just
uh did he just compliment you or was it
me as well it was just me
i knew it i knew it you wouldn't have
shouted them out if it was the book
i compliment you okay so i don't think
you need from anybody else who's
watching the show
all right let's get back to the game
no i'm going to leave that and buy it
but i compliment you i don't mean like i
give you comments but i am your
complimentary piece here in the
broadcast oh that's what i thought you
meant
you would never admit to actually
praising me on air uh
you know we uh night a7 i'll have our
moments
this night just come see this is exactly
what i mean by the yonda palmishi of
like the new version of him he makes
these moves i gotta get this bishop out
here and i don't mind
which some people they succumb to
psychological pressure no i can't move a
piece where it just came from he said
this is objectively the best decision
i'm impressed by him right now
yeah knight back to c6 and he is
preparing the movie five of course icaru
is not going to repeat and knight c3 is
very unusual in these types of positions
i think the mitigating factor is that
hikaru is aiming for b5 normally it's
white always plays c2 c4 to challenge
the center but hikaru he doesn't hurry
with this
knight a4 wow
what do you make of this i think that
bishop is going to move back to a7 so
the blacks minor pieces are going to use
that square rotate through it and bishop
d6
exactly i didn't want to lie to that ice
skater
i didn't want to allow the knight into
b6 which is why i chose a7 but dania
black's foundation is very strong here
but what's the actual plan
yeah because white's plan is essentially
clear right queen e2 and you're
preparing c2 c4
now the sort of equivalent idea for
black ideally would be e65 but in order
to prepare that you would have to play
something like bishop b and we already
know what's wrong with that that allows
the knight to jump into b6 so very
interesting choice by hikaru to place
his knight on a4 it's got a lot of
potential energy and it's holding
black's pieces back but yan he tries to
exploit one of the drawbacks of knight
c3 to a4 which is that the e4 square
is no longer under white's control
for sure and i guess he'll just continue
developing actually bishop d7 and things
like that and um
if the knight wants to hop back to d6 at
some moment so you can't lose sight of
that if you're hikaru
i know you want to play c4 but at some
moment a 96 retreat could be annoying
yeah it could i actually like black's
position here i think jan has done a
great job
of you know neutralizing
yukaru's
opening and c4
the fact that he takes e4 is a discovery
there's a hikara move if i've ever seen
one i think he's intending queen c2 in
response all right it makes a lot of
sense and i would play probably knight
d6 here just to
kind of force
hikaru's hand hitting the c4 pawn a
second time also attacking this bishop
but
it's getting unclear so i really like
this move c4 from ikaro we know that's
what he wanted to play but i thought he
would have to spend an extra tempo to
make it work
yeah the position beginning to heat up
here i 96 is a very young type of move
look he's just sipping on his teeth
he's so
zen
did this guy attend like a 10-day
retreat or something he's just
so calm it's crazy it really does seem
like he has worked with like a sports
psychologist because in madrid where we
were commentating live
he would every single interview he would
say i'm just thinking about the next
game the next move right he didn't
talk about the bigger
yeah he didn't talk about the bigger
picture at all so for jan
i really believe that he's had a huge
shift in his mentality around chess and
it's paying tremendous dividends
yeah because if you remember the yan
from us a couple of years ago
he was very emotive at the board
you know
losses often broke him this is a
completely different person we're
talking about here but back to the game
big question for hikaru what is he going
to take on c4 with he takes with the
pawn and this is a very interesting
construction robert if you take on b5
that pawn replaces the bishop and that
might be even more unpleasant than
keeping the bishop on b5 he might just
lose a piece actually b6 yeah trapping
the bishop on a7
so knight takes b5 not gonna happen just
yet but now it's more of a threat with
the rook staring down the queen on c2
oh for sure it's a threat takes and then
there's all sorts of shenanigans 95
knights e4
at the very least icaru will probably
have to reposition his queen to b3
and then
it's hard to find moves here
for both sides yeah
even every single individual choice is
not easy and that's why hikaru is now
down a minute on the clock so he goes
queen to b3 like what if yon passes the
baton back to him and plays like bishop
e8 just like i mean
white does have improving like rook ac1
h3
so i'm not like too concerned for
hikaru's supply of moves bishop e8 is a
great move they're reopening the d file
and he might play f6 at some moment and
use that bishop over on h5 or
maybe on f7 and then e5 and go out for
the c4 pawn so
there's a a clear target that white
needs to be worried about i agree
and so i think that's the reason why
hikaru trying to exploit his biggest
asset arguably which is his central
control preparing to double on the
defile
and look at january he still seems very
calm it's hard to tell with respect to
hikaru because he there is that delay
from his stream to this broadcast but
for yan he's been the same pose the
whole way through and he does play
knight to e4
and
[Music]
is he aiming for like a knight c5 at
some point i'm not sure i think he's
aiming for
a trade of
both pairs of rocks yeah queen d3 rook
d8 still right d yeah because the rook
on v1 is unprotected
makes perfect sense we might see a
large-scale liquidation in the draw but
the position remains incredibly sharp so
very hard to predict which direction the
game takes
and uh i think dania that if jan's given
the opportunities to trade pieces and
make sure that he can't lose he'll do
that because he gets white in game two
and well we know how dangerous yonder
palm she is with the first move
advantage
incredibly dangerous especially
in these rcc finals and there it is
steadfastly following
his plan offering a trade of the second
pair of brooks and he can't really
refuse that i mean i don't see him
playing him like knight d4 that looks
there's something incredibly flimsy
about that white also can't take his
eyes off his king right if you abandon
the king queen h4 could come at some
moment knight takes f2 and whoa whoa or
by hikaru
speaking of
holy smokes that move felt incredibly
unnecessary and
i was going to say before h4 that in
certain positions and even in end games
that white doesn't need to be a little
bit careful because of the split pawn
structure on the queen side but i think
that now
white is kind of setting himself up
icaru is for a potential issue this h4
pawn for example could become a target
your knight would have to stay on f3
defending it so it's getting
interesting right now not problematic
but
it just feels like a situation where
both sides need to be a bit careful and
interestingly jan
refrains
from trading that second pair of rooks
and he plays knight t6 closing the d
file back again
and is he really trying to take on b5
once again there's that issue of the
pawn replacing the bishop and forcing
the other knight backward to b8
although if you can trade rooks as well
then i might go to d8 i'm not sure that
actually improves all that much but it
at least doesn't get your piece trapped
queen d1 by hicaro intensifying the
pressure along the d-file i'm not sure i
love the move knight d6
but you called it there's that f6 idea
and now you really regret h4
right
because after bishop h5 if only the pawn
was on h3 you'd be able to play g4 on
demand
oh you see the eval bar i'm not sure why
but it's going down in jan's favor here
is it because of bishop g6 or bishop h5
it's hard to say
e5 threatening e4 is tempting
although you'd have to reckon with the
weakening of the d5 square but what
you're saying is that even knight d5
might not be that dangerous
yep i didn't calculate it through i'm
just you know throwing out kind of moves
but yeah it does look a little bit dicey
so maybe we should come up with a
different move first
and you know what's interesting about
this moment donya is we're we're just
talking about how jan is happy to make a
draw because well that's what he came
into this game hoping to do but right
now with more time on the clock with
white split pawn structure and the queen
side with some holes in the position do
you think jan is in kind of
not i mean
risk everything to win mode but do you
think he's feeling this position like
hey i should really play for a victory
for sure i i think his last couple of
moves including that knight d6 move on
move 24
is a pretty sure-fire indicator that he
wants to keep some life
uh in this position but hikaru
essentially forcing a trade of rooks
this move knight e4 obviously the knight
is untouchable because black loses the
rook knight b7
seems to be the most natural move to me
you could also defend the knight with
bishop b8
so i definitely agree that hikaru is the
one who has to tread more carefully in
this position yeah 94 was a good
decision to take on c6 and go like this
knight f7 you have to be careful of
tactics related to a potential
bishop takes f6 later down the line with
you know some sort of a fork
you see what i'm saying i definitely see
what you're saying oh there's a cool
line rook takes the queen takes the
queen takes the knight takes the e8 it
looks like white has bishop takes f6 but
this inter mezzo wins a piece and it's
because the knight on e4 also hangs
after bishop takes d8 oh it's a really
good variation to point out because
bishop f6 tactics are hanging in the air
here but let's look at what's happening
here if the queens get traded bishop
takes us
will not be played that's the blunder
i like black's chins you have the bishop
pair
yeah
and you have the potential to
shut down white's bishop with that movie
five which also creates new prospects
for black's bishop to attack the weak c4
pawn okay it really looks to me like
white is much worse here
oh that's a good move though
before trying to force things off the
table wait but bishop f3 gf3 then bishop
d4 ed4 i guess black's knight is very
passive at the end of that but white's
pawn structure stinks and you could
potentially push the h pawn to h5 to
give yourself the later option of
creating an outside passer with g7 g5
that's a huge asset in most night end
games but i agree with you the passivity
of black's knight
might counterbalance that and give white
uh great drawing chances here here we go
he's going for it
i
i'm nervous yeah i'm nervous for a
carver's position here for sure
he obviously is not better he can't
create a past pawn of his own and as you
were correctly indicating h5 g5 at some
point down the line if the white king
tries to go towards the center of the
queen side that is going to be scary and
h5 for white might only exacerbate the
issue because it eases the task of
creating a passer you go king f7 and g6
so he does push a kingside pawn but it's
the f pawn which he pushes to f4 maybe
trying to
further discourage jan from ever playing
the move g5 so what's wrong with king f7
just bring our king up into the game
i think that's what we're going to see
fighting f17 g60 f5 and
car will have to bring up his own king
in a timely manner
and another nah that's probably too
risky i was thinking can black at some
point play a4
to get his knight to a5 but we press f5
instead eval bar didn't like it
i was going to propose this move because
that allows black's knight to activate
to d6 right
looks very natural honestly but now you
need to be careful because if white can
push c5 in some position the knight gets
out to c4
yeah that a pawn
that a bomb is a very serious liability
any especially if blacks knight
moves toward the center
f5 might have been rash
by young
now white has a clear path to a past
pawn so that's the good news black
actually
doesn't right that's it's weird we
thought black was gonna have a pass pawn
at some point but now
white is the one who will have an
unopposed
pawn but i guess the king is coming very
quickly the center for black
yeah i could see this fizzling out into
a
neither side can make progress kind of
situation i can also see this getting
really sharp
in the event that hikaru pushes c5 and
he just did
and jan started drinking some tea and
now he's
laser focused after that move c5 well
the threat is obvious i mean hicara
wants to play c6 and promote his darn
pawn
can yon get away with d3 using that pawn
as a decoy to keep white's knight at bay
i guess after d3 white will bring the
king in like king f1 kg1 king d2 and
maybe
just try to corral it that way
and black should probably do the same
maybe king f7 and
i don't know about e5 but
there is a lot to calculate here for
both sides but d3 c6 so knight d6
there's king f1
hmm
well knight takes a5 is now a
threat i think he car was gaining the
upper hand here somehow some way
can jan go the other way you can go g6
h5 but that's so slow
it feels very slow just because a5 is
just hanging over there like take it
right on so knight knight takes a5
uh-huh where's black's king going
because you can't go k8 king d8 because
there's knight b7 check and i'll be a
winning king and pawn ending i think
we're going to see king f6 and e5 no he
goes to e7 so he actually might be going
this way no but you can't go king d8
you're right no you're absolutely right
knight b7
ah but he's gonna move his knight first
where
i didn't have to answer that question
but if he moves to b5 white moves his
knight back to c4 defending a3 and
covering the d6 where at the same time
wow hikaru is just
how he's such a magician it's crazy
okay so knight e4 oh he's playing knight
b7 anyway and he's cut the black king
off oh my god
and the past apon is going to be
a massive danger for black
okay there must be a way to save this
position 9994 it is
like c4 the choice i think knight b7 was
a better try yeah the eval bar
immediately went to even but it was not
that big an edge for white regardless
but
it seems like allowing the black king to
c7
it's making theon's task much easier yes
and hikaru is still trying he pushes the
knight out of e4
probably
i was thinking just knight c5 but maybe
this
oh maybe knight c3 to d5
oh
oh my gosh are you having three result
possibility again
well if i can get to this h41 he's gonna
have a three on a four on one on the
king's side
and the pawns could potentially be
self-sufficient there
wow so yeah knight c3 king d2 knight d5
i'm getting f4 so same idea by the way
okay we need
i mean if he carver really wants to make
a draw
he can probably play knight takes d3 in
response to knight h5 or knight t5
but why not h5
don't know
just the worst square
that's a very strange move
oh
and look what he's done
now his knight
needs to waste
loads of time getting back into the
center and this apron on the outside
passer yeah and she can use a decoy in
the white king's no king d4 king e5
giannis be very careful right now it's
still a draw but
in a time scramble if hikaru can give
this pawn away and get his king to e5
imagine defending that with 30 seconds
no thank you because now you're this is
where you use your finger and you point
right you're king b4 king d4 king a4
king e5 king b4 qd6 like you're like
that's exactly what you have to do
but i think what yana's trying to do is
engineer a situation where the king
stops white's king division of labor the
knight is running to d5 just in the nick
of time so that a6 can be met with a
fork
that's pretty clever
desperately searching for ways to keep
winning chances alive
yeah i almost wonder and i was about to
say if knight f5 f8 excuse me should be
thrown in because now knight d5 of
course just hangs the e6 pawn if you go
king d6 you've already
let the white pawn start running and the
white king to advance oh my gosh
king c4 but apparently that was in the
movie i think d4
was the move or was it a five
it's one of those situations that with
one min and the clock you can hardly
blame the players king c4 seemed very
logical to use and it's still
incredibly black is walking on hot coals
here
right so king c6 king d4
king d6 a5
there's like knight
i'm having the same thing i'm a knight i
don't know where to let go because every
move has obvious drawbacks there's no
way jan should have allowed this and now
he carries the only one having fun in
this end game
one minute yeah the clock continues to
dwindle and that knight on g6 is a hero
it's protecting both of white's weak
pawns and stopping the g pawn from
pushing
yeah this is the worst kind of position
to have against ikaro he knows how to
squeeze
every single chance out of a position
like this
oh oh check on e5
okay you know knight d3
seems crushing because the knight gets
to b4 and the pawn is unstoppable it's
winning hikaru's played a brilliant end
game i mean he did not play that well i
would say he was getting outplayed let's
put it that way by jan earlier but ever
since they've reached that night end
game it's been all hickart it appears
that h6h5 was the only drawing move in
that position totally impossible to play
wow it's over no this is some impressive
technique from ikaro straight into the
end game textbook
night before night before and start
pushing the pawn
yawn maybe one last idea to play e5 and
breakthrough with g5 this game is not
over yet
e5
he's got it
so a6
a6 black will maybe even
take on f4
and a7 i guess your knight can always
hide on a8 when my knight tries to the
tempting option is f e and king c5 but
then jan will play g5
and his pawn is real quick
i guess the knight can come back to d3
with check that's right and then to f2
or f4
it's quick but it's way too slow yeah
it's over
yeah this is done
curtains g5 knight d3 check and
just knights are so bad at defending rim
pawns
yeah no the and it's on the worst
possible score it's on c7 which means
there's a total sitting duck after king
of c6
wait ninety five track doesn't that just
win on the spot yes
and hikara will not miss that
jan can resign a6
just a6
it's almost like yan having precisely
zero problems in the opening was bad for
him because he didn't have to work too
hard in the early stage of the game and
then later when he was doing completely
fine he made his f5 move which was the
start of his problems i would compare
this almost to the end drake and fedex
game
where
you know yan just didn't really as
you're saying he didn't really
conceptualize the fact that he might
actually be
in trouble
and underestimating the weakness of that
apon i think that's what it all really
boils down to
i mean i still think it was just such a
phenomenal end game by hikaru nakamura
we know how good he is in all time
controls but there was something just
exquisite about his technique there
where it didn't really feel like yon did
anything majorly wrong even f5
it wasn't like one single move it was
just a series of moves that was not
really
uh together and how many people play c5
in this position like this is vintage
chicaro not recapturing automatically
giving black's knight purchase on the
queen side which probably would have led
to a draw
but instead finding a way with his
meager resources
to create
loads of winning chances just crazy and
then he put his knight on g6 and that
night was incredible there
it honestly defies belief but the second
game is underway and jan has his work
cut out for him
and here's another catalan and hikaru's
going to go for his dc and b5 lines he
got better have something up his sleeve
oh there it is he's going to force icaru
into a different line oh
b6 6.
i don't
really know that move but jan clearly
does and so does icarus i've seen this
before there's an exchange sack for two
pawns but i feel like i've seen it
with the black pawn on b4 almost
i guess there's a different right
yeah this is some crazy prep so black is
what two pawns for the exchange
completely irrational position the white
bishop probably coming out software
that's all i can say for sure
the bishop is probably going to come out
even that i don't know maybe it'll come
out to e3
but now hikaru is the first to think and
that's probably a good sign for yon and
if bishop f4 i was about to say it's so
scary g5 might be an option but
uh i like white's position
no this is
jan could not ask for a better position
out of the opening in a must-win game he
has guaranteed
himself winning chances in this game if
he plays properly material imbalance
exposed king potentially for black with
everything you could ask for and a
slight but growing lead on the clock for
yan who has more time than he started
with exactly and he's
again i'm just conjecturing here but
he's probably gonna bring the rook to d1
from a visual visual standpoint robert
this looks incredibly unpleasant for
black i mean what do i know right the
position is irrational
so the engine leads the way here but you
can move your knight you can't move your
bishop because you drop a7
how do you untangle here and i guess
that's the answer knight f6 to d5
creating
a potential pawn phalanx on the queen
side in the center i think jan is just
he's crazy well what i would be worried
about if i were hikaru is
not even is just is this candice prep is
this world championship prep and
hikaru while he is playing well right
now
jan seems to really know look at this
one come on h4 he shakes it bishop f4
bishop takes b8 cutting off the defender
of the bishop and winning a piece yeah
h4 is definitely a move you play if
you're not prepared
you know wink wink
yeah i think you just improvised that
this smacks of improvisation honestly
robert why would you think this is prep
come on get your story together yeah who
am i i'm really worried for a car here
it's like one of these things where if
he solves it he's like dingly ran
against a car in the candidates where he
car played like 27 moves of prep and
then dingley run held and just played a
brilliant game of chess or he's just
gonna get blown off the board and then
there are two options he played the
human move of course and
that gone young thinking which is very
might be the happiest car has been all
game
or all match
so
is the plan for white to essentially at
some point play bishop d4 king g2
exactly you you're on the same page
which is why i think bishop takes g5 is
very much in play here but he car takes
to the pawn and
no no this looks really bad
and maybe bishop f6 should be considered
but then
it's a bishop d4 is not the only problem
rook h1 and queen c2
is just as dangerous in fact that could
just lead to checkmate right out of the
gates
yeah
so um
hmm i think this is an opening that
he car is going to regret playing
because it's super sharp and jan just
knows it better
h i can't get over h4
that was some crazy preparation and
that's the great thing about the rcc yes
he's pulling out canada's preparation
and no that's not overkill there's 30k
on the line and these players are taking
this as seriously as an over the board
tournament they certainly are and i mean
what a time to
unload your preparation
in a must-win game the second game of
your match against a car and i mean if
we're being honest donya this game
it's not set in stone but it could
decide the winner of the rapid chess
championship because now you have the
benefit of even if you lose in the grand
final you still get that second match
where you don't want to have to be
clawing back when you uh have no choice
but to win every match you don't have
the luxury to say yeah okay i played a
bad two games let's get it next time
yeah the loser is dropped into the dog
pit of wesley against andre
so
that is far from a guarantee
and hikaru is at a loss here
so trying to prevent a loss
yeah i'm trying to figure this out
though because one thing i'm noticing is
the bishop on f3 is out of squares so if
i can make a move that threatens g4i
maybe it's f5 maybe it's queen g7 i i'm
not sure which one but either way if i
can threaten g4 that
might be a tempo saving move and maybe a
game-saving decision
so what is white's response to f5
because the threat of g4 is believe it
or not not that easy to pair you don't
really want to go g4 yourself and create
king side weaknesses allow bishop d6
maybe just rook h1 honestly and if g4
played bishop b4
it's like i don't care about that bishop
i've got all i need
takes takes
gosh this looks horrible yeah
the eval bar shut up to
justify this decision because the e file
also opens up and that means when the
rooks combine on e1 and h7 black just
gets massacred in the center this is
brutal and hegar is spending all his
time wisely because he knows that it's
if he doesn't find the accurate move
here he's just lost hmm
i just don't see this
working out for him he's down at five
and a half minutes
i could easily in an over the board game
we'll put it this way he would probably
spend 30 40 minutes here at least yeah
exactly and and and
to have to make a decision in three
minutes is nutso and he plays queen f5
so he goes for your idea preparing g4
and moving the queen out of the line of
fire of white star square bishop a
sensible decision but g4 for white now
rookie one
just if does it just feel like white's
play is too easy
and that's reflected in the speed of
nepo's moves he's definitely out of prep
at this point right
uh not even sure rook h5 yeah yeah you
never know at this point rook hybrid h1
autopilot
you know what i consider for your cars
like rookie 8 takes bishop e3
yeah you might as well i'm not sure it's
any good but my point is that i feel
safer for at least like two moves if i
do that but no you'll have rook h6 uh
this looks so terrible yeah if you go
down two exchanges also that knight
albeit it's dead and so is the bishop
you're playing down two more minor
pieces
if he gets out of this i
[Music]
there's takes d5 also but then rook
takes e3
or b5 maybe
uh-huh
true
no i think there's no reason to reinvent
the wheel i think dh1 is
plenty sufficient
not sure why yon says he's standing
there he is there he goes
this is just so brutal like
is down
four minutes
his king is in grave danger
and you know what's missing is the white
queen so i don't know where the queen's
gonna infiltrate from but like a move
like
yeah like exactly as you're showing
maybe queen a3 just to keep the to keep
the pressure alive go to d6
no you're absolutely right the quinn has
done its job halting
the development of black's queen side
pieces now it's time for the queen to
join the attacking effort
and massive effect look at yon by the
way he knows that he caught hikaru
yeah he nikara's clock continues to
dwindle he's now down to four minutes
and the problems merely grow and grow
it's hard to make a move here for black
every single move has some downside
well i thought king g7 might be the most
reasonable because rook h6
might be the most immediate threat
because that allows white's queen
to dive into c2 in one fell swoop
true
what do we say here there's nothing to
say i'm i'm speechless d4
okay bishop bishop takes g5 and rook h8
check
oh my gosh i was looking for the the
tactic and yeah you found it more
quickly than i did
oh yeah it's gonna see that especially
since this bishop is literally attacked
yeah right square he's forced to see it
and he if he does another blow he car
probably will drop back to g7
then bishop h6 and rook g5 oh this is oh
there's also bishop f4 to take your
knight on b8 oh god and rook she five
every move is a threat
yeah it's true
no i in in all
fairness to ikaru this is what happens
when you walk into a well-prepared
opponent like it was a sharp line you
didn't know every single move that you
needed to find to make sure that you
could maintain a level game or at least
a game that was playable and one mistake
already it was like plus three so yeah
it happens to everybody in fact yonder
palm she lost do you remember that game
to vishy anand
uh in a grunfeld he lost like 17 moves
as black because
he didn't know the theory or he forgot i
have to refresh my memory but
i
yeah yeah
i i know a lot of games like this and
the monday morning andes the armchair
andes are going to say why did the car
go for the sharp line would he sacked
the exchange
he only needed a draw
but he car just played what's in his
repertoire right he didn't deviate from
his opening he just didn't expect john
to pull out canada's prep this
particular moment
right and bishop f4 looks like it ends
the game the fastest yeah you just trade
rooks and the b8 knight is loose and
even if it weren't loose you're already
threatening to take it because the
bishop is going to hang on a6 so
that's the thing the car might resign
after bishop f4 but the hikaru effect
we've seen people lose their minds
in these types of positions against them
um i'm looking at yon's body language
and he doesn't look like a guy who's
about to throw this game away that is
very valid he also has eight minutes
like
one question i was thinking oh does he
really need to think here his win seems
pretty straightforward but it's good
that he's thinking because he has plenty
of time and he's completely winning he's
also enjoying it yeah he's enjoying the
process of finding the winning move
because he knows it's there
and he knows the result of the game is
not in question well you know what he
was really doing donna is he was doing
game theory and trying to figure out
what he's going to bid in the armageddon
right now this is disgusting
just done
that knight on v8 never moved a muscle
and now it's gonna be captured what a
miserable existence this has only been
23 moves by the way
no i mean hikaru got obliterated and
this just does not happen to him at all
ever
two minutes on the clock he's down five
and a half minutes in a ten minute game
just repeat that to yourself has a car
ever been down five and a half minutes
in any non-classical time patrol
and i don't think he car is actually
gonna be too upset with this game
because
this happens right this is a an on-site
accident that just happens to chess
players from time to time it doesn't
matter who you are
and this is the particular game in which
it happened bishop takes e5 is actually
possible oh and rookie chain mate
oh look at that it's a sleek line
wow that's actually sick
nepo though he keeps the tension between
a5 and he car resigns the game
or does he no he doesn't he does yeah he
hasn't yet but you made a really good
point and i think it's an important
observation because if you think about
how these games have gone i actually
think yan is the one who should be more
upset because he had a good position
with black and then got outplayed
whereas hikaru just entered a line that
he wasn't super familiar with and got
crushed and that sounds worse right
getting crushed sounds worse than losing
a long game but no because he card
didn't like he didn't get outplayed by
jan he just got wiped off the board so i
think as we head into the uh bidding
here i i believe that both players i
mean i think jan probably wants white
and a car
i don't know if he really wants white
because he didn't get anything out of
the opening
yeah and jan's gonna or he car is gonna
have to improvise on the fly because
hicaro has been playing this particular
line of the catalan for the past year
plus so he's going to have to pull
something out of his pocket something
that's been sitting
you know on his on his chest base for a
while because they cannot repeat this
hikaru cannot afford that even if he
finds an improvement
jan knows this line backwards and
forwards that was obvious
so
i'm just trying to get the mentality of
the players right now if you're hikaru
you probably want black because you're
very fast you're not too worried about
getting in time trouble but if you get
hit with more candidates prep then good
luck to anybody no matter how much time
you have and if you're young you were
doing pretty well with black you just
stumbled an endgame and with white you
just crushed him so what color do the
players want
i mean they might hedge their bets and
bet something like eight minutes seven
and a half minutes we've seen players do
that where they say okay i'm fine taking
black but you're going to have to give
me a pretty generous amount of time
yeah
i really don't know what i would bid if
i were the plus i think if i were
hikaru i would bid
seven and a half minutes i think why i'm
struggling so much is that
while hikaru is faster than everybody
jan in classical chess is faster than
everybody so he knows his stuff and he
puts pressure on the clock it's just so
it's such an even match up i guess
yeah it really is and we're in as akilah
is saying in the chat for a legendary
armageddon this is just going to be one
of those games you can feel it in the
air you know this is going to be an epic
game you just know it
and
i mean hikaru's armor has been cracked
right he has been borderline invincible
in so many of these events right
throughout the rcc season he was making
all the knockouts winning plenty of them
he's won in all these title tuesdays yan
you know he scored some victories here
and there but wasn't as consistent and
didn't play as much but now we'll see if
jan naponshi if he has what it takes to
take on our next hired player resume
hikaru nakamura i really don't think you
need to
read his resume because you should know
everything about him
he is just an absolute legend of the
chess world he is a four-time speed
chess champion
and a five-time u.s champion so if you
didn't think he could play classical
you're wrong you already know he can
play blitz so what a legend this guy is
yeah i mean
there's just nothing to talk about if
you don't know who he is and what he has
done
where have you been then it must be day
one of your journey into the chess world
and that's okay if it is
yeah no we welcome you with open arms
exactly here for the first time click
that follow button you know do follow
the channel so much more action
including tomorrow so we do appreciate
that uh you know if you're new please
come back if you're
a veteran chess watcher and you know
they also come back
we appreciate you
and if you're a veteran chess watcher
you'll know that you know what you said
earlier is true hicaru is going to be
irked that he fell into this preparation
but he's not going to be upset his
confidence is not going to be shaken
because it's not like
he played his best and he still got
destroyed he fell into prep and his main
goal in this armageddon game if he gets
black
has got to be to throw john off because
john's work in the catalan from the
candidates onwards has been absolutely
immaculate and he's pulling out all the
stops you just know it in this arm again
gabrian is pulling his a-game
preparation out of the box and we see
the players there on camera briefly
they're probably typing in their bids
just make sure everything's in order and
yan he looks like he typed something
that immediately wanted to get out of
the chair um they might have the jitters
right even though both players scored a
victory there it's
armageddon is just it's odd it just it's
exciting for fans for sure but for
players
it's nerve-wracking i can feel my heart
beating faster and faster it always does
but this particular armageddon
is
just the cherry on top and we remind you
that the loser of this game still stays
in the tournament has to face the winner
of the match between andreikin and
wesley so
fun stuff well you know what's fun to
hear is both players very confident
because hikaru nakamura chooses seven
minutes and 30 seconds and gianna palm
street chooses 10 minutes so jan wanted
the white piece i wonder which color he
wanted to play with what do you think
i'm not sure hard to say with his bid i
mean it might be both really he was
hedging his bets yeah i think he was
okay no matter what but ten minutes was
the ons but he wanted the white pieces
and it carved down a seven and a half
minutes meaning he's comfortable with a
deficit in the clock two and a half
minutes is quite a lot of time right
that's
that's a lot that's a fourth of your
time gone before the game even starts
and there's no increment so it's
dangerous territory
yeah and the last thing john wants is a
time scramble we know who will probably
win in a time scramble it'll be hikaru
he's more experienced he's the superior
bullet player by a country mile so jan
has to try to step on the gas pedal from
the very first few moves big question
will hikaru play in nimzo indian or will
he go for a queen's gamut client my
guess is he might go for a queen's game
of decline or queensland accept it
because he used to play that almost full
time a couple of years ago well look at
jan i don't know if he's praying or just
pumping himself off maybe beatboxing
over there but he's ready hikaru
nakamura also ready and dania if i'm
thinking about this from a match
perspective i don't think jan should
repeat the same line because hikaru gets
a few minutes all it takes is oh gosh i
should have played this move order and
everything was okay and i just realized
you can still play the catalan against
the queen's gambit decline so maybe
queen's gambit accepted
is being considered by hicaro but i
agree you should deviate just a little
bit but he's definitely playing the
catalan right he's not going to deviate
from the catalan yakara couldn't have
done that much homework in the last five
minutes yeah and there's so many
different variations right there's so
many variations but it car
there we go i thought he was up from his
chair but i forgot that it's a minute a
difference between uh
uh his video and what we see so yeah he
is obviously playing moment of truth
so he's going to go for the main line
which i think is a very sensible
decision bishop b4 and probably c6 which
is the fashionable move
right because oftentimes in this
position you're trying to play c5 you
desperately want to play c5 as black but
white is trying to prevent that from
happening
the bishop travels back to g6 this is
the modern treatment of the catalan i
think according to the latest
assessments white has a minuscule tiny
edge you often see the move knight f3 to
h4
threatening c6 going for the bishop pair
but
hikaru has already got you i'm thinking
that is a good early sign but look at
yawn he finds the principal move knight
h4 opening the bishop on g2 trying to
get the bishop pair so look at this
moment is bishop takes c6 a threat it
looks like it to me because a takes b5
to follow so um
i'm not sure with you maybe queen b6 a
standard type of move is you're showing
rook seat as well it's very unclear
but rook c8 does contain the drawback of
giving up the a5 but the subtlety is
that 865 can actually be met with c
takes b5 that would threaten the move
before the placement of the queen on c1
is imperiled by black's last move a very
complex middle game as jan activates his
rook and x-rays black screen in return
so i was going to say that hikart won
the opening battle but now i like yan's
position and it's not just because of
what's happening over the board it's
just there's no clarity and with the
lead on the clock i think that he can
continue to build up the momentum in the
position because a car has played very
fast
and fast he is playing as he moves the
queen from d8 to c7 paving the way for
the rook to enter the game via d8 no
question in my mind that jana is better
right he's got a slight stable advantage
to bishop pair but can he keep his foot
on the gas pedal i like to move a b5
here forcing black tick with the a pun
which opens up the rook on a1 but you
can also make a maneuver like knight a2
and then go to b4 so i'm looking for
that i think i'm taking on b5 first so i
don't drop the a4 pawn though maybe
that's also okay but i think that
maneuver will lead to an advantage for
white john's strategically investing
some time he's got to keep a hefty time
advantage he's got to try to stay at
least a minute up on the clock because
if the time situation equalizes
even if jan is clearly better that's
going to be a very disturbing sign for
his
chances of success yeah you do not want
to be in a bullet brawl with the bullet
chest champion that's for sure although
jan is a 3100 bullet player himself he's
not like some of the super gm's who
really struggle with just a minute on
the clock he's he's had a free move
let's put it that way he does indeed he
brings his rook up to a6 and b5 is a
threat it's a big threat and even if
you're a queen b7 it still could be a
threat not immediately because your rook
is under attack but you're putting the
queen on a pinned
diagonal will young drop back to a2 in
order to try to shift the queen to a1
and infiltrate down the a file
very good question because queen a1 is
meant by rook a8 that doesn't look all
that appealing for white
you've bitten off more than you can chew
in that case now jan could go back to a1
and repeat moves
but he's already sunk a lot of time into
this decision he needs something to show
for it and rook a5 is his choice that's
very clever big b5 is now also a threat
if the knight moves rook takes b5
happens and in other variations where
the rook was on a1 the black knight
could enter c4 as you're indicating so
now maybe knight b to d5 instead he goes
queen b8
i don't love that i feel like now white
has great control over the a file would
you play queen a1 here or would you
prioritize the improvement of the bishop
i love queen c2 because he wants the
rooks doubled that is the optimal way of
seizing control of the a file and i was
going to answer your question with yes i
was going to play queen a1 but then i
saw yon's move i'm like nope that guy's
better at chest than i am let's follow
his moves it's so clear that jan has
such a deep command of this position
it's so clear that he's done his
homework not just in the sense of
opening preparation but in the sense of
understanding what the middle game ideas
are and for the time being he's kept a
hefty time advantage he's doing
everything he needs to do and i think
that's where some uh fans can
state that players just memorize they
you know have all this preparation
preparation isn't about memorization
it's an understanding yes hikara got
trapped last game but right now hikar
actually tricked yeah not tricked him
but surprised him and yan has been
answering the call perfectly so what now
done if the e5 he takes we have a four
on three advantage on the king side for
white we have a two on one for black
that's an interesting sort of imbalance
in terms of pawn structure and we have a
standoff between the rooks on the defile
now a big question for why do you take
on d8 the upside of that move is that
black will have to recapture with the
bishop in order to keep c6 protected but
jan chooses to keep the tension
intensifying the pressure not only on
the knight but by extension on the c6
pawn that is the main target which he
needs to try to encircle with his rooks
and his bishop i actually love that move
because the black brings the knight to
d5 after knight takes d5 you might stick
with the pawn on d5 and now you have two
different isolated pawns b5 and d5 white
also has the bishop pair so it's looking
really nice for yonder palms and look at
the lead on the clock still remains two
minutes
back to two minutes and hikaru has
burned
through a significant portion of his
time he might have to bring his queen
back to defend b6 but then you've got
all sorts of shenanigans with knight
takes b5 that you have to process
this is a very unpleasant position
especially from a practical standpoint
because eon keeps asking harder and
harder questions on every move and i
think hikar likes shenanigans as much as
the next guy but not right now in
armageddon chess he takes on d1 so
how do you take back do you think with
the queen maybe there's a quick knight
c4 hitting the b2 pawn look at yon
taking with the knight opening up his
bishop from e1 to the a5 diagonal now i
bet a silver dollar that he would not
take on c6 i don't even know why i just
don't think he's gonna no no no
he's done crazier things wait a sec is
there bishop h3 rook c7 bishop a5 kind
of stuff ooh
with a pin against the knight but jan
chooses a more conventional move as he
reactivates his knight and hikaru shoots
the rook away from a6
rook back to a1
but this advantage feels lasting for
white yeah
yeah this is like john's game against
fedexiv this is taking on very similar
contours of course icaro is stronger
he will not panic
and if hikaru can set his queen side
pawns in motion robert if he can go c5
and b4 he actually might turn his
weakness into a strength
and that's why i think that white needs
to operate from the e through h files
you have an extra pawn there i'm not
sure h4 is actually useful but at some
point maybe e4 e5 then bring your knight
to e4 things like that it's getting
mixed right it's a mixed bag here but i
feel like white needs to operate towards
the king side the evan barlow continues
to know and their ghosty car with his
queen side pawns b5 before a big move
asking jan a question of his own okay
and look at that response let's let's
trade those knights off
and after c5 maybe just like a queen ace
oh he trades i think this is going in a
good direction for hikar i think he's
still slightly worse than the end game
the bishop pair white's command of the
light squares in the center gives white
a lasting advantage but this is an
easier position to handle for hikaru
than that middle game
yes and we did see on draken take down
fedo seven in equal ending with this
kind of pawn structure right so you need
to be careful if your car not to let
those pawns roll up the board
but he car look at how he's managed the
time he's only spent three minutes it
feels like he spent so much longer than
that but he's got
an ocean of time left on his clock rook
d8 might be on tap here and if the rooks
get traded
how is jan going to approach
those weak queen side pawns with what
right you're gonna have to start pushing
the king side pawns but with what you
don't have many pieces of remaining so i
think that ultimately a move like bishop
to c4 right bishop f1
yeah
going for something like that and also
keeps pieces on the board and that
prolongs the game which is good for the
side who's up on the time yeah jan has
to find where prolonging the game is
absolutely crucial because even hikaru
has to spend a certain amount of time in
this situation and what a bold decision
moving the pawn to g4 immobilizing
white's entire king side that's a deep
freeze if i've ever seen one and maybe
h2h3 should be considered to unfreeze
the pawns and i think that black will
play move f5 the car will probably have
to extend on the king side which could
get his king trouble later in the game
so c4 not available with b4 pawn being
loose but maybe tactically it can work
out and that's why young puts the bishop
on d5 now he definitely prevents c4 but
hikaru aims at the bishop moves the rook
back to d8
just get the sense that he is playing
with a lot of confidence here knight b5
knight c3 is another idea that jan has
to has to reckon with and knight b5 to
d4 now but maybe
just maybe white can operate around that
night there is no king d3 though because
the knight fourteen knight takes b3
becomes available thanks where did you
go where did you go to e3 because then
you have to reckon with an axis oh so
king back to f1 just
run away i suppose so
but that's a pretty big win for black
and if he wants to force an opposite
color bishop position which is what he
says oh my goodness
he's doing that
unbelievable game by akaro
i mean this defense is
to say its textbook is to say nothing
this has been surgical filigree
precision but he needs to finish the job
and h2 is hanging by the way like which
she might take
if king e2 will probably go knight d4
check back because why allow the game to
continue if you can almost force the
draw but
what a game by ikaru here
i mean every move
has been something to learn from and yan
has to find a way to keep the flames of
initiative going but they're getting
extinguished move after move car is not
losing this no i think you have to play
bishop d2 here and now you chop and
do it
no i mean jan's not worse
but winning this
it's tough but it's possible the one
asset for jan is the fact that the
bishop cannot move he's got to but how
he can't approach these pawns again he
doesn't have anything to attack them
with because they're on dark squares he
needed to approach the f7 pawn but that
f7 pawn no longer exists so good move by
a car on f6
and the moment you move the bishop
black's rook starts to run amok jan can
barely move a muscle here yeah i think
he might have to move his rook back he
was a b7 i thought he was going to rook
a1 rook h1 rook h4 just try something
over there bishop b6 bishop d7 maybe
or or bishop c6 might be a more accurate
way to do this
bishop e6 is really annoying cause
bishop d6 king d5 and all of a sudden
white's just gaining control of the
board that's the only way jan can win
this game is by bringing his king
into black's grill but he's not doing
any bishop b6 is a and he plays there he
goes just
okay king d5 kings is actually quite
worrisome
and the time situation has equalized so
the only way jan is winning this right
now is on the board
well
you know this position actually is
starting to look a little bit troubling
but not maybe
bring that king in that bishop on e7 is
just bad
yeah it's got nowhere to go it's got
nowhere to be other than this diagonal
and now you have to really watch out
with the king coming to c6 for like
bishop takes g4 bishop e2 bishop c4
check the black king could be in some
danger
king c6 i think is going to follow right
now
he wants pokemon to put his rook on a
light square can't fault him for that
now he car could consider rook aid
making sure for activity bishop g4 for
sure
oh
six and then oh he wants to keep going
to e6
will he play e5 now
it feels like a movie you might have to
play but you don't really want to
is rookie six okay he stops 56 for now
okay so rook a3 runs into king e6 that's
the big issue
which is actually a really big issue
continues to defend with unbelievable
accuracy so far watch out because e5 e6
is actually oh
oh oh rook b7 oh this is getting really
dicey and here's the problem robert the
king is going to migrate to f5 which is
an amazing base of operations
and you definitely can't go after this
b3 ball you're just too slow the time
advantage is up to 40 seconds so if
you're going more unpleasant if you go
rook a6 there's gonna be like a rook bh
check e5 coming the pawn is pushing up
the board oh my gosh yonder palm she's a
miracle worker he's created a pawn
majority on the king side out of thin
air
here comes so desperate to stay in the
game here's e5 and the big problem is
the c5 b4 configuration it's immobilized
by just one pawn so one takes care of
two of the queen side now it's one on
none and that's a fast break attack and
he's an up now an entire minute on the
clock with the car dropping below two
minutes with no increment no it's
incredibly promising for yon without
increment i don't know how you survive
this but if anyone can do it it is
hikaru nakamura he brings kingdom fate
jan could consider the strategy of just
maintaining the status quo for a couple
of moves squeezing black's clock as much
as possible before embarking on
something concrete and i think he wants
to bring his bishop ultimately to c4 but
now he can't accomplish it so easily but
what's black's move he should be able to
flag him keep going to create activity
push a c4 tape that pawn with the pawn
you can't take with the king because the
bishop was loose
king back to e4
and now the bishop has a safe haven on
d5 and the king can re-maneuver back to
the center with king f5 king e6 or king
g6 i think objectively i think
objectively this is winning over the
board but especially with hikar's clock
situation i think it's just no chance i
mean the biggest thing jan has to avoid
of course is a a rook trade and b he has
to keep black's pass pawn at bay and
he's got to keep his advantage on the
clock and here comes that king there's
no bishop d4 because bishop d5 was
available go rook b5 just attack the
bishop
bishop has to drop back to e7 or it can
be defended by the rook mm-hmm
so how does white make progress though
that's the great question rook be it
maybe go around rook hit but then you
run the risk of letting the pawn run
amok although you can play rookie chain
after b3 go right back to b8 and get
that pawn and that's exactly what yon is
thinking the evil bird drops though no
it's coming back up b3 and rook a3
oh that looks so passive overkill okay i
thought he won a rope but no the bishop
protects he's gonna repeat once but that
allows blacks no he's not going to
repeat
okay he's playing aimlessly here and
hicaro has made some improvements to his
position and jan has to stop the pawn
laterally now which is not desirable no
that's not where you want them
especially because rook a3 offers a rook
trade which you cannot afford to do but
that
check on h8 for sure
and get the rook back to b7 keep the
status quo hikaru is under a minute yeah
bring that rook
e6 check is mighty tempting
and i think john's going to do it e6 is
the best opportunity to push the spot he
said all end game long and where's that
black king going to go after e6 i think
he six wins the game
he goes
oh he goes more conservative well the
problem for black is b3 never works
because you can't push that pawn any
further and the white pawn is going up
the board so
what is hikar gonna do is 45 seconds he
goes rook a1 now it's e6 time the flag
should be pretty easy just avoid a
three-time repetition put the rook on
five yeah put the rook on b5 right now
and maybe even c5 the c pawn and the
bishop will stop the b-pawn from d5 as
well
so rook takes b4 this rook f1 or no
there's no rook of one's king e4
car's still down a minute he's down to
30 seconds he's spending 10 seconds of
move and king e4 now
this should be an easy flag for you
maybe kingy for bishop c3 and somehow a
car is staying in the game but i would
push the c pawn at that point and just
again keep the status quo every move
hikaru has to take at least five seconds
this is unsustainable no this is not 28
seconds
oh there's just no way he's got no time
king
f7
and back to king eight king eight is
king just winning i think it is and then
e7
he's still up a minute hikaru
desperately pushes he wants to checkmate
him with the yeah
he wants bishop c5 but you can just take
and then after bishop see if i play e7
yourself it's elementary my dear watson
and this is exactly what's going to
happen no check on d7 and back to f3
i was wondering what he was doing it
seemed a little bit weird but he blocks
the rook his path to f8
is unavailable
it's over
rook b7 is possible at some point there
it is and rook f7 also is oh rook d7 is
not mate but i thought it was right d7
and e7 king d8 as long as he avoids
getting checkmated he's going to win he
called down to five seconds with no
increment and he resigns what an amazing
game from yanupongshi like that was some
stellar technique
done it we can't forget that hikaru
narrowed the gap on the clock it was
almost even on time and yawn
amped up the pressure and wins this game
so if kara nakamura is not eliminated he
goes to losers bracket but dania what a
performance by both of these two
absolutely unbelievable
carlos start another game here let me
close that out
when we went into that opposite chord
bishop band game robert the time
situation equalized as you said i was
sure the game wouldn't end the draw and
it is the hallmark of the best of the
best to whip up chances out of nowhere
he pulled a magnus did yanukovych what
an amazing effort as he makes his way
into the grand final and let's not
forget he lost game one from a position
that looked borderline unlosable then he
struck back in game two with a wonderful
just masterpiece of an attack and then
in game three as you said it was a
magnus-like effort he outlasted car in
opposite code bishop ending he deserves
to move on and carl is still in this
thing he goes to lose his bracket he
awaits the winner of wesley stone
demetron draken but right now donnie and
i are gonna take a short break when we
return we come back for the coinbase
rapid recap here at the rapid chess
championship finals presented by
coinbase
the rapid chess championship is brought
to you by coinbase whether you're
looking to make your first crypto
purchase or you're an experienced trader
coinbase has you covered you can earn
crypto by learning about crypto at
coinbase.com explore d5 and web3 with
your coinbase wallet get exclusive
rewards when you spend with your
coinbase card and much much more learn
more at
coinbase.com and get 10 in bitcoin when
you sign up and verify your account
check them out use the command sponsor
or command coinbase today and go to
coinbase.com to get that bitcoin baby
and we are back not a very long break
but the moment you're waiting for the
coin base rapid recap begins now because
we have the game between ikaro nakamura
and yonder palm shield or should i say
yonder palms university car nakamura
because danya game two of their match it
was phenomenal
it was indeed and it was made all the
more spicy by the fact that yon lost
game one in a painful end game it was a
textbook effort by hikaru and the first
thing yon does is turn to his trusty
catalan he has been playing it
successfully all
rcc long he played it to defeat fedexev
in the armageddon game yesterday he
plays it once again against ikara
nakamura but robert ikaro and the
candidates in his last couple of
tournaments has shown stellar
preparation against the catalan so jan
in this moment does something a little
bit different than usual
yeah he makes this move queen a4 which
goes right after the c4 pawn now we have
seen a6 followed by b5 in fact we saw
that in the armageddon game which is
standard fare at
any level against the catalan but here
your car plays the move b6 or dania it
allows tactics on the long diagonal
because the rook on eight it's eyed by
the bishop on g2 and of course the car
saw this and this is well known jan
immediately bounces with 95 which leads
to an exchange sacrifice queen takes d4
and hikaru captures the 95. so
technically black might even we can say
up a little bit of material black has
two pawns for the exchange but the
underlying problem in black's position
is his terrible development these two
pieces on the king side keep a close eye
on them because
spoiler alert they essentially never got
out of the gates but jan's preparation
from this point on robert was beyond
impressive it was magnificent because if
you look at the position right now and
the reason bishop a6 was played was a7
and c4 were both targeted so you deal
with both at once but now the knight on
b8 is stuck defending this bishop on a6
which is stuck looking at its own pawn
it's the way the game continued with
knight c3 very natural move and now
here's a big move by hikaru a good move
and likely was something he's looked at
in the past g5 covers f4 so no bishop f4
but dania in just a couple moves from
now we see why g5 has his problems
we do and first order of business for
jan is to complete his development
bishop e3 knight d5 by hikaru leading to
a trade and this may seem favorable for
nakamura he's got all these pawns in the
center
it looks pretty promising for black yon
brings the rook into d1 to keep the d5
pawn on the band after c6 may be the
most impressive move of the game h2h4
out of nowhere and this is a cannonball
of a shot because if he carver takes on
h4 he pays the price for his lack of
queen side development white plays
bishop f4 forces the queen back and
whoop takes the knight off of the game
and what do you mean good bishop for bad
knight why would you do that well the
bishop on a6 is now left without a
defender and if you try bishop b5 the
queen joins the bishop just in time and
that led hikaru to make the decisive
concession
yeah it was out of nowhere except for
yon's chest base because he prepared h4
likely for the candidates it was a great
time to use h6 that seems like a very
logical move we were just talking about
bishop f4 is the problem but in this
position already it's super sharp ghana
and probably there's only one move if we
just go back before h6 and already the
position looks like black is about to
lose it looks like queen takes b2 which
is like the most counterintuitive move
ever but you're definitely defending
your king by creating past pawns you're
distracting white's pieces later in the
game but that is an impossible move to
find when facing preparation a rapid
game this would have led to crazy
complications one can forgive ficaro for
playing the natural h6 but the big
problem with this move is that the h
file is now open and that is a permanent
problem for back which john immediately
exploits with the classy king g2 paving
the way for the rook to uh migrate to h1
creating absolutely devastating threats
against icarus king now hikaru he tries
to evacuate his queen to a safer square
but robert it was essentially too little
and too late as jan's pieces pour into
the king side with decisive effect and
yeah the rest of the game was quite
natural from whiteswag look at this rook
up the board let's go to h5 the next
rook joins the party with rook to h1 and
after hit carl finally started getting
his pawns rolling it's too little too
late because bishop takes g5 another
tactical move munching on the pawn
because you'll get a rook if you take
that bishop so the car tries just to
keep the game going but it's not really
getting anywhere because the knight on
v8 at long last is hunted
phil agree precision to end the game by
jan as he drops back to f4 indeed
hunting down the night and after the
trade on h5 hikaru plays bishop c8 and
without awaiting yon's move which would
have been rook h6 or queen c7 anything
is winning here hikaru decided to resign
the game that led to an armageddon which
was arguably an even greater masterpiece
for yon as he defeats ikar nakamura
making his way to the grand finals and
that was your coinbase rapid recap
yonder pandashi an absolute hero in this
match and in the rcc as a whole now what
a performance by him his invitation to
the rapid chess championship seems very
warranted he moves on to the grand
finals who will he face we don't have
the answer that because if you look at
the bottom of the screen here in the
gray wesley so he lived to see another
day and so does demetrion draken so
those two will square off the winner of
that match gets the
lovely lovely prize of taking on hikaru
nakamura and the winner from there
gets some shot at yonda pomgy now yan he
is the favorite to win this event
because he has two lives if he loses a
two-game match he gets another one right
from there so jana palmerjee he must be
thrilled with the day he has had he
defeats hikar nakamura if they're losing
game one danya we gotta just tip our
proverbial cap to him over and over and
over again because he took a punch but
he immediately got right back up and he
delivered the fatal blow to ikara
nakamura and now gianna ponchi he's the
one that everyone is trying to catch
his form is unbelievable his preparation
is crazy he has so many tricks to pull
out of the bag
this is jan 2.0 we talked about this
might even be gone 3.0 because not only
does he play the catalan not only does
he now play the petrov but he's playing
with such energy he's playing with such
passion he's not just playing for a draw
with black and for a win with white he's
playing for a win everywhere he's
playing with tremendous precision
calmness tranquility
and amazing energy jon has been so fun
to watch this tournament car nakamura
drops down to the loser's bracket he's
got a chip on his shoulder he's defeated
wesley and on draken plenty of times in
the rcc and hikaru wants nothing more
than another stab at yonda pandushi in
the rcc finals and as you're saying
hikaru's defeated them numerous times
but they also are two of the players who
claim that they've also beaten hikaru a
number of times so nothing is set in
stone from the losers bracket it will be
super fascinating to see what happens on
championship sunday but for now donna
and i are going to head out we want to
thank everybody who's been tuning in
donna i'll give you some final words
before i wrap up the show and let us go
it's been such a treat to watch the rcc
and to commentate it with you
you know this day promised to contain
loads of action and it did it did not
disappoint and i'm not just saying it
because i gotta say it i would have
called it out if we didn't have enough
action but we did we had an amazing
armageddon to cap off the day and i
cannot wait for 12 eastern tomorrow
where everything will come to
what will hopefully be an even more
amazing close i can't wait either so
thanks again to you partner thanks to
everybody who's worked so hard to make
this event possible to the players to
the fans and as we conclude day three of
four here at the rapid chess
championship finals brought to you by
coinbase for daniski and all the staff
working hard behind the scenes i'm
robert hess and we'll leave you with a
recap of today's stream enjoy and see
you tomorrow we're excited it's gonna be
another fun day
oh my goodness look at this position
look at the rook on h1 it's oh by the
way every square is controlled oh my
gosh
talk about domination ding doesn't have
to do anything you can put a rook on e3
and go eat lunch yeah this is painful to
look at no this is over they drew
they drew
that's a pity draw offer but it wins the
match so who cares okay but father has
no connection i see okay now it's back
are you seeing this like it goes to no
yeah yeah the red oh he's down to one
bar again no no dimitri made a move he's
done oh my gosh
oh he's gotta move he's disconnected he
doesn't know oh
wow that is absolutely tragic
this is what he's done he's down in four
seconds he's gotta move two back one
move
move he's gone he's gone
oh my goodness no
terrible
bishop g6 just take the oh my god
rook c five no
no that was in the move oh rookie five
king of six and rook seats mate
oh my god and i don't see a different
move for fedex king f6 and e6 he's going
oh my gosh
oh he is king d8 f6 oh he can't do king
d8
because of rick d7 check winning the
bishop and now he's gonna play e6 it's
complete it's over
rook move oh you knew trade roads trade
bishop g687 oh my gosh or even the
immediate rook d7 wins the bishop
it's over
holy cannoli but it'll save can't
believe it okay i love moves like that
because i was so tunneled on taking on
f7 bishop d1
bishop d-1-1-0 and i didn't notice it
i'm pretty sure ding noticed it there
was no need to give up that pawn at all
and you see wesley clapping
ikaru nakamura and yon napomshi to
determine who will be slot into the
grand final and who will drop down to
the loser's bracket to await the winner
of wesley so versus demetrion draken
here we go
he's going for it
i i'm nervous yeah i'm nervous for
hikaru's position here
for sure this is just so brutal kikaru
is down
four minutes
his king is in grave danger look at yon
by the way he knows that he caught
hikaru no i mean hikaru got obliterated
and this just does not happen to him at
all
ever
super excited
[Music]
so
you